the infamous plot to kidnap Gretchen
Whitmer new information has come out and
you know what I'm not even gonna give
you my thoughts I'm going to give you
the thoughts of BuzzFeed news who
analyze and report on this saying that
this latest information that's come up
come out about this supposed right-wing
plot raises questions as to whether or
not there would have even been a
conspiracy were it not for the FBI as
they had had a hand in every aspect of
it including its Inception now BuzzFeed
gets extremely close to saying basically
the FBI started it organized the people
set up the meetings and essentially told
people what to do and now many of these
defendants are arguing that they were
set up some are even arguing entrapment
now how many people are surprised by by
this how many people commented on my
video when I report on this saying Tim I
bet you it's the FBI and I was too uh I
don't I don't think I entertained it
enough I'm not I'm not big on uh I guess
as much as people try to claim that I
predict the future all the time I I only
see so far so I had a bunch of people
commenting they're like this reeks of an
FBI staying of a setup and this is what
the FBI is known for I mean they do it
so often some people have argued that
basically what they do is they find some
mentally unwell people go to them on set
them up and then say Oh look what we
found and then some person ends up in
prison and they can claim that they did
something important and it was I guess
effective politically for Democrats to
say oh no look at these right-wing
extremists which helped fuel this fire
of the right and the white supremacists
and the militias being the most
dangerous threat in this country so why
now why why is the story coming out why
are why are anyone why is anyone in the
mainstream media entertaining this I
guess we'll have to dig into it and
start talking about what's really going
on we also got some other stories too it
turns out you know I did a segment at 4
pm over on my my main Channel Tim cast
or I should say my my Solo Channel
timcast and uh talking about this Texas
Democrat super spreader event where
these Democrats from Texas go to D.C and
a bunch of people get covered we got new
reporting out that several staffers
several aides
a ton of people who were at this
Democrat Texas thing are getting covered
even even fully vaccinated people so I
gotta say it's a super spreader event it
was irresponsible and uh let's call it
that double standard so we'll get to
that we'll talk about a bunch of other
stuff we got some aocs in the news
because she's selling merchandise and
doesn't know what capitalism is so he
can talk about what capitalism is and
joining us today is Pedro Gonzalez
associate editor of Chronicles a
magazine in American culture I believe
that's right Joanna just quickly
introduce yourself yeah I'm uh happy to
be here
um uh yeah it's been surreal uh the last
few I guess like the last like six
months I've been doing a bunch of these
different shows and I'm I'm uh I
appreciate you bringing me on uh I saw
that you threw up a tweet of mine
recently I think it was maybe critical
of like porn or transgenderism I don't
know but when I saw that you put that on
your show I thought like it's a matter
of time before I get on oh yeah what
what is Chronicles magazine oh yeah so
it was founded in
1977 and it has always been this kind of
outside dissident voice not just in the
in things that are political but also
literary and for years it has been kind
of like the lone voice in the wilderness
of populism uh it was for a Time the
intellectual Flagship of the Buchanan
movement it explained and Justified
buchananism uh many of the same
arguments in Chronicles that were
developed there actually ended up being
completely
uh seamless with the Trump movement Rush
Limbaugh read an article by a guy named
Sam Francis who wrote an article for
Chronicles in I think 90 in the early
90s and Limbaugh read it and I think in
2015 to explain the Trump phenomenon so
interesting it's a small magazine but it
punches way above its weight and they
have been basically right for the last
30 or 40 years and it seems like the
rest of the country is kind of just
catching up right on so we'll get into
all that stuff thanks for hanging out we
got Ian chilling what's up everybody Ian
crossing over here just sipping on some
coffee with a little uh collagen and
maybe we'll get into that in a little
bit yeah it's the spots absolutely
delicious and I am also here in the
corner Ian was trying to get ahead of us
by asking Peter all these cool questions
because I didn't get into all of that
stuff tonight right on before we get
started we have an excellent sponsor
tonight we have bio trust's ageless
multi-collagen just go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can
secure your supply of ageless
multi-college and up to 51 off today my
friends this is the stuff you need to
make your bones your joints your hair
your skin and Nails healthier and more
Supple and um if you're somebody who's
trying to eat healthy you're trying to
stay fit you you especially if you're
trying to exercise and do sports that
are high impact you know I skate all the
time so I'm falling bouncing on the
ground this stuff's incredibly important
but it's also good for your skin makes
your skin Supple and nice so if you
really want to take care of your health
go to stronger bones and life.com and
check it out you get a 60-day money-back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms the five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources essential to optimally
support an array of Full Body Benefits I
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits for every order
today BioTrust will donate a nutritious
meal to a hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no
kidhungry.org to date BioTrust has
provided over 4.4 million meals to
Hungry kids police help BioTrust hit
their goal of 5 million meals this year
it is non-GMO and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners and free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and RBST no odor or
taste unlike bone broth and other
collagen supplements there's no clumping
unlike other collagen supplements free
shipping with every order and this last
one I was raised it's amazing free free
VIP live health and fitness coaching
from BioTrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order I mean that's worth it right there
man free new e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order and I'll
I'll just say right now
Ian you threw some of that in your
coffee I did how's it how's it I love it
Tim fantastic yeah thank you so go to
strongerbonesandlife.com thanks by our
trust seriously for sponsoring the show
uh it it means a lot really does and
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member and you'll get access to the
exclusive members only podcast segments
check us out just right here on the left
doesn't the new website look so amazing
we've been getting a bunch of messages
from people are super excited
obviously there are some bugs we're
working out for that I apologize but we
just launched it it went up on Saturday
so we could work out some of the bugs
for the weekend and we're still
improving and making it better we got
new shows coming we've got a Bonus
segment coming up tonight which usually
goes around 11 or so p.m so sign up and
don't forget to like this video right
now on YouTube click that subscribe
button and the notification Bell which
apparently does nothing but hey do it
anyway and then share the show with your
friends if you think what we talk about
is important take that URL paste it
wherever you can let's talk about this
first story we got this from the week
defendants and alleged Whitmer
kidnapping plot are arguing FBI
informants engineered plan now I'll just
say this I mean that's that's a heavy
piece of what we're going to talk about
it's one thing to make that accusation
it's another thing when BuzzFeed news of
all Outlets comes out and says there are
questions as to whether or not there
would have even been a conspiracy were
not for the FBI and then there's
questions of law do you think that
Federal prosecutors are going to drop
this case simply because now being
exposed by the media maybe not but it's
possible I just really doubt it there's
not going to be political willpower and
especially when Democrats want to use
this to their advantage but let me show
you this so this is the story from the
week right and they're basically
pointing out the the section of the
BuzzFeed article about the defendant
saying they're accusing the FBI of
effectively orchestrating this BuzzFeed
dot BuzzFeed news says an examination of
the case by BuzzFeed news also reveals
some of those informants of which they
were 12 acting under the direction of
the FBI played a far larger role than
has previously been reported working in
secret they did more than just passively
observe and report on the actions of the
suspects instead they had a hand in
nearly every aspect effect of the
alleged plot starting with its Inception
the extent of their involvement raises
questions as to whether there would have
even been a conspiracy without them I'll
do you one better BuzzFeed I can
appreciate that they put that in there
that is an opinion however but I can
give my opinion when you when you go on
to mention that a longtime government of
informant helped organize a series of
meetings around the country where many
of the legend plotters first met one one
another yeah there wouldn't be without
the FBI they they set the meetings so
okay look
the FBI is going to argue hey hey we
gave them the space and we we made those
statements but they made those choices I
don't know what do you guys what do you
guys what do you guys think it's
disgusting I think it's only it's it's
incitement unless the FBI is doing it
apparently it's only illegal unless the
president does it like come on Trump
trump didn't say anything anywhere near
as as crazy as these people were saying
if if the if the eye goes to somebody
that's mentally unstable and puts a gun
in their hand and says encourages them
or points them in the direction of
someone that they want like that's
how can you blame that that I guess you
got to blame the gunman but but
obviously you blame Charles Manson when
the other guy went out and stabbed the
people they were giving these guys
military training
what do you think about it Pedro
this is what the FBI does I mean this is
what the feds do they
create these plots they provide the
training the logistical coordination and
then they basically entrap their victims
and so the question is why do they do
that right
I think there are different answers to
that I think one it's politically useful
because Trump is bad Trump was a fascist
of course I'm just being sarcastic but I
think so it's politically useful from
that angle at least for the Democratic
party but on the other hand I mean this
is this is good business for the FBI
right this is job security if you have
these kinds of threats if you have these
kinds of coordinated very dangerous
highly motivated actors then you you
need the FBI you don't just need the FBI
the FBI needs a bigger budget it needs
to expand its operations into different
aspects of not just public life but also
private life it needs to know more about
what Americans are doing so that it can
make sure that these things don't happen
and the fact that the FBI is you know
the driving cause of these things
happening well that's just a little
footnote that we don't need to really
get into I don't think there is a
solution to I don't think there's an
easy solution to corruption that's an
easy solution you know I'm thinking
about like okay what if we didn't have
government FBI right what if we had
private investigatory agencies and you
hired them instead of having to go and
make a petition and cross your fingers
hope they actually look into the case
maybe you go and hire a company well
then any company could be incentivized
to do criminal activities for for the
sake of making money right so let's say
you're a window repair company and you
know you're you're a private company you
make money when Windows get broken
certainly excited when you hear antifa's
rioting so any any any individual who is
sufficiently corrupt or who has
monopolistic power could be susceptible
to saying okay how can we encourage more
riots and support some more of this
activism encourage this stuff because
inadvertently it allows us to sell more
windows actually Ryan long had that that
comedy segment did you see that one
where it's like antifa window repair and
he's like we're both simultaneously
antifa and the window repair company but
anyway I digress when you have the FBI
and they have a monopoly on this and
they want to make money and increase
their budgets there's one way to do it
you need a large and Powerful Big Bang
well here you go they had a dozen
informants so it Internet it's an
interesting point first
what is entrapment
this this probably is not entrainment
entrapment would be when you coerce
someone by force or or threats so if a
cop went to you and said
if you don't do this I'll hit you that's
entrapment if they said hey wouldn't it
be really awesome if you did this you
should totally do it that's right that's
not entrapment you still chose to do it
the problem is there's a fine line right
I mean you you actually have the FBI now
creating the means the the the the
providing the resources these things
can't happen without them right like
who's going to give military training to
a bunch of random meme you know-ish
posters on the internet that's right no
it gets into this question like you said
these Blurred Lines right where it's
kind of like Choice architecture
you're laying out all of the instruments
and arguments and logistics for doing
this and you're also exploiting people
who are desperate and angry and may be
mentally unstable
and your defenses will I just put the
gun on the table I don't have any
responsibility for what that person did
afterwards after I told them to use the
gun and how to use it and who they
should use it on that's not my fault Ian
made a good point man it's incitement it
is it seems like incitement I mean
they're they're encouraging them or
getting them revved up or connecting
them to commit a crime it seemed like
let me let me let me pull this part of
the BuzzFeed article they say this
they say Dan steered let me move back a
little bit let me move back so I can get
to that point in the context they say as
agents in Poland and Chambers listen in
Dan pressed him about the meeting in
Ohio Dublin fox said was about changing
the Paradigm the media treated Patriots
unfairly after he and hundreds of other
Patriots occupied the state house in
Lansing they effing called us domestic
terrorists that's a quote quote we want
to take that stigma off and let them
know who we are because we are not
effing racists we are not white
nationalists said Fox we just want our
effing Constitution upheld and we want
all these Lawless effing tyrants out of
effing power it's that simple Dan
steered the conversation away from
rhetoric to specific plans asking Fox
what the mission was like what are we
looking to go forward with laughing fox
said his dream was to have quote have
the governor hogtied down on a table for
public display the way the DEA DEA
agents spread gun season drug spread
seized guns and drugs across the table
like trophies after a big bust quote we
take the building and then take effing
hostages foxtel Dan it's effing war time
but by his own admission Fox
despite his new seemingly Grand military
title was a general without soldiers I
can't do nothing with less than 200 men
he complained to Dan at best he figured
he could muster maybe 15 to 20 men
stopping violent ideas like this was
what Dan said drove him to law
enforcement in the first place but now
with his two FBI agents at his side he
told Fox he would help
they're effectively inciting and
encouraging their creating circumstances
it's incitement Donald Trump can say
we're going to go peacefully March and
listen to some politicians or whatever
that's what he said right has something
like you know have politicians make
arguments and then As Trump was speaking
the people at the Capitol started
pushing the barricades down fighting
with cops storming their way up to the
of the capital and fighting on at the
front door
Donald Trump did not do anything near
what this is but they say that there was
a Tweet now I can't I think it was a
Daily Beast I'm not sure they were like
Trump's failed attempt to overthrow the
government or like someone some news
Outlet tweeted that like they're just it
even the media they're just continually
escalating what really happened on the
sixth like Donald Trump gave a speech
where he in no way said go do this stuff
he was like peacefully March and now
they've just slowly turned it into
something totally different like the
Lincoln project made this video where
it's a mishmash of what Trump was saying
to make it seem like he was calling for
violence
yeah I tell you man it's dark days ahead
huh well there's something related to
this so
we can say that the Capitol Police
failed right on January 6th they failed
to do the job because some conservatives
argue that they facilitated what
happened through their failure however
you want to slice it okay well Tucker
says the FBI had had informants they
were probably orchestrated as well yes
that's right so but we'll grant that so
these people either out of negligence or
malice they're part of the reason why
January 6 happened okay
so what happens after January 6. well
the Capitol Police has a two billion
dollar budget with which they plan to
expand operations outside of the capital
first in Florida and Florida and
California to the most popular states
with plans to open field offices across
the country they've also borrowed eight
they're called persistent surveillance
systems from the US government the Army
is going to train Capitol Police to use
these we first deployed this technology
in Iraq and Afghanistan to monitor
asymmetric threats in other words we use
this technology against insurgents so
now Capitol Police which is supposed to
be in the capital is expanding
operations across the United States
ostensibly to protect members of
Congress and they're also going to be
deploying technology that we used
against insurgents on Americans in order
to what this stuff does is you can
create I think it's called pattern of
life it allows you to monitor people on
a very intimate level to figure out you
know where they eat where they sleep
where they go what their routines are
and things like that but over large
geographical swaths this this is uh this
is not like a like a little camera right
this is huge surveillance on a mass
level
this is fine apparently no one really
seems to have a problem with it and
people are buying the argument that no
the Capitol Police needs to do this they
need to expand operations to these huge
States or actually to all as many states
as they want and they also need to
deploy military good equipment that we
use on insurgents because Americans Mike
cernovich has been tweeting about this
saying that you know he often hears
someone start trying to ramp up the
rhetoric and push it towards some kind
of direct physical action and he always
shuts them down he blocks them or he
kicks him out because he's like we we
don't want any of that we know where
that's going and he's right I keep
telling people you know peaceful
persuasive resourceful that's how you
win a culture War that's how you you
maintain your country and one of the
problems there's two big problems and
one conservatives people on the right
the anti-establishment the anti-wok
dispected liberal liberals well I should
I'm going to exclude the dispected
Liberals mostly the right as we've
traditionally known it very weak on
culture very weak I mean you know people
people mock these like the religious
conservative movie productions and
things like that the daily wire is doing
a pretty good job getting into this the
one one big Advantage I think
conservatives have right now are
disaffected liberals many of whom were
in music production and movie production
and show production culture building
wins you the youth and 10 years from now
there's going to be another generation
entering politics and what 10 year olds
are being inundated with today is going
to severely impact what politics will
look like in 10 years so one thing that
we saw
I bring up every so often is that you
know we've had some leftists some
younger left us on the show and they
have no idea what Occupy Wall Street was
they were they were young teenagers when
that was happening and just had no
understanding of what was going on so
now when I base my disdain for Joe Biden
off of a lot of the Obama era they're
like I don't know anything about that
right now you look at what's happening
with with children and the the
indoctrination at schools these kids who
are in these schools getting
indoctrinated 10 years from now are
going to vote as far left as humanly
possible if conservatives and people on
the right don't fight back with
persuasive resourcefulness with
resourcefulness with persuasion being
peaceful and building culture you lose
especially when you see what's going on
with the FBI they're looking for any
opportunity to take that frustration
turn it into some kind of uh some
expressed desire for action and then
lock you up and then it gives them even
more justification for indoctrinating
kids it's just one after another one two
three Punch Yeah I think maybe one
example of a positive development in the
culture is that movie about Richard
Jewell
the security guard who is basically
screwed by the FBI after he he managed
to save a ton of people I think it was
at a baseball game it was some kind of a
sporting event where there was a bomb
and uh basically the feds put it on him
right that he the three they argued that
the reason he was able to find the bomb
and save all these people was because he
had in fact planted it
and the movie was interesting because
Richard Jewell is like your average
middle American he's this guy who
doesn't have like a college degree uh
he's just patriotic patriotic
kind of naive about his country and I
mean that in a good way
and here he is being absolutely
railroaded by these horrible corrupt
feds right and I think that that movie
was really interesting precisely because
that
you have this patriotic person who's
being persecuted by his own by the own
by his own government you do not talk to
police that's it it's simple there's a
famous Supreme Court Justice can
remember his name long time ago said do
not talk to Cops and it's funny there
are a lot of conservatives that seem to
think they're very they're very naive
about this country is and it's it's
funny when you see the the uh you know
very the very heavy back of the blue
like attitudes kind of waning a little
bit with the coveted lockdowns and stuff
um people are you know many people on
the right are starting to realize like
uh I think you know what man we shout
out Michael malice too much Michael you
could shout out too much but he he often
says that there is no law so uh you know
absurd or disgusting or amoral that a
cop would not enforce it now that may be
a bit extreme because I certainly think
there's many things a cop wouldn't do to
be honest however the proud Boys versus
antifo is a really good example of this
that they got into a fight because
antifa had been harassing and patrons
one guy got gets robbed and then finally
the proud boys are like all right you
want to fight a lot of people see the
proud boys run towards antifa but antifa
had been basically like at every corner
following them and as much as they keep
trying to walk away they see anti-foot
every corner eventually the proud boys
decide they're going to engage well
first of all that's a mistake don't
start fights you can you can try and go
around them you can try and walk past
them they run at them a fight breaks out
okay well if antifa shows up they're
known to be violent the fight breaks out
we can argue that sometimes fights
happen I still think it's wrong but what
happened after that antifa flees the
proud boys decide to give a statement to
the cops because we trust the cops the
cops are the good guys and now guess who
went to prison proud boys antifa none of
them yeah no this is I think you're
right this is a kind of eye-opening
moment where
basically what we've seen for the last
year or so is this kind of a
narco-tyranny where
you're right and the conservatives are
right to say that there's this effort to
kind of defang the police or at least
get them to back off of policing a
certain kind of crime in a certain kind
of criminal
but that doesn't mean that they're
actually de-policing they're just
focusing more on enforcing things like
mask mandates or like you said or uh
arresting proud boys and people like
that a good example is this guy Jonathan
Petland there's a drill instructor
at a base it's in the South the the
specific state of Louisiana right now
but basically this guy got into a
confrontation with a suspect who
happened to be black this guy was like a
repeat offender in the neighborhood what
you don't what you didn't hear from from
the stories it broke was that this guy
had repeatedly come into this
neighborhood and harass people and
specifically had grabbed uh young women
made them feel very uncomfortable
there's a claim that he's like mentally
unstable whatever okay but but here's
the part that the story that the news
really didn't focus on was that the
police had actually known about this guy
and they let him out like they knew that
he was walking about but they the
argument was we didn't want to make him
a statistic so when people would report
him to us we would kind of slap him on
the wrist and then let him go and he
would go back into this community and
harass people so one day a woman goes
and gets this guy Jonathan Petland and
says he's back you know do something
about it and he goes and confronts the
guy and you I don't know if you saw the
video oh yeah it goes viral he says
you're in the wrong neighborhood uh he's
really confrontational for right reason
because there's things that happen
leading up to that the police absolutely
destroyed Jonathan patland's life They
Crucified him uh within 48 hours there
were people at his house throwing things
through the window the military
completely disavowed him his own unit
framed him as a white extremist a white
supremacist like the guy's reputation is
ruined in the thing and he was just like
like uh trying to be a middle-aged guy
who saw someone harassing women and
doing the job that cops wouldn't do
because they were because the cops were
more concerned with avoiding the the
stigma of being called racist and doing
their jobs this is the perfect example
of why I have been saying abolish the
police and it and it is somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but not completely the
point I'm trying to make is if we are
really moving into this era where the
police know we can't go after anybody
who might be defended by the left
because we don't want to deal with it
and we'll lose our budgets but we can
arrest anybody on the right all day and
night and get praised for it then what
do you think is going to happen in this
instance the cops they knew that they
knew this guy was they don't care about
this guy John Petland's life who seemed
to be according to the story a regular
guy who was like these young women in my
neighborhood are being harassed by this
guy I'm Gonna Make It Stop and he did I
watched that video and I'm like what did
the guy really do he like got got up to
him said back off back off get out of
here and pushed him shouldn't have
shoved them push pushed him when he was
walking towards his wife which was
actually the thing that the police the
sheriff uh the the I don't know the
sheriff Chief whatever said that's
that's like the evidence right there for
rooting this guy's life is the fact that
he he shoved him what of course but you
see in that video is that the guy starts
approaching his wife he's like he's his
wife says something to him and the guy
starts walking towards him instead steps
on his property and that's when he
shoves him and says that's my wife and
that's when the cops are like that's
that's where he crossed the line when he
shoved the guy and ruin a guy's life
because he pushed somebody yes because
the left claimed he was racist for for
shoving a young black man saying you're
in the wrong neighborhood so it's like
social pressure that ruined this they
used social pressure to try to ruin this
activists politics social pressure
pushing because because initially
initially he got uh it was basically the
equivalent of like a citation because he
slapped the guy's phone out of his hand
right okay but then pressure is mounting
you know there's this outrage in the
community about this racist white man
who's telling like a young black man
he's in the wrong neighborhood and so so
the police went back and said oh we have
new evidence that shows that you know he
shoved him it's like that's not new that
was the video that went viral uh and
that justifies ultimately the penalty
was like it was like a short like a few
days in jail and like a a five thousand
dollar fine or something it was really
small but that's that's nothing compared
to the damage to this guy's reputation
like the the HOA where he lives like
disavowed him in a statement saying that
like you know racism has no home in this
community and like I said the HOA the
police the military the media as far as
these organ these entities that I just
named are concerned like this guy is a
vile racist who does not belong in
polite Society his life is ruined this
is like they they say often that a
history doesn't repeat but it Rhymes you
know that that phrase this is just such
a great example of banishment and how
banishment has kind of come back around
now and now we have this social
banishment ostracization conservatives
need to call the bluff of the left they
need to call the bluff and say we hereby
believe all cops should be abolished and
there's two reasons for it you see what
they'll do to this guy you see what
happens anarcho tyranny they will not
enforce the laws to protect you but they
will enforce the law against you and the
second reason is y'all are gun owners
why are you worried about petty crime in
your neighborhood and what the police
are going to do about it if the left
wants to abolish cops if cops are then
willing to ruin a man's life not every
single cop I know call their Bluff
because how fast do you think we saw
this in Minneapolis when when they were
like we want to abolish the police and
then the city council is like we hereby
vote to abolish the police no wait stop
don't do it the city council members
panicked and freaked out so I'll put it
this way I've had leftists tweet like
Jim Poole only wants to abolish the
police because he knows that when the
when the police are gone the leftists
will get really angry or he thinks they
will and I'm like well that's partly
correct right I am 100 confident if the
police actually got abolished you will
see every regular American wake up and
that's one of the biggest problems frogs
boiling in a pot conservatives can sit
here all day and night and say if we
don't stop the the the tide from the the
flood waters from rising if we don't put
up sandbags we will drown and people are
sitting there just like I don't care
it's not flooding in my house and then
within a month they're on the second
floor being like I don't I don't care
like I'm safe here on the second floor
okay call them on their Bluff say okay
look I'll put it this way the other the
other point the other side of this is
that may be part partially true that I
definitely think the moment you actually
try to abolish the police regular people
will come out screaming begging you to
stop but the other issue is exactly
we've been talking about it's only a
matter of time before we see more police
arrest regular people we saw with the
mccloskeys people actually go onto their
private property go onto their lawns the
mccloskeys come out okay they shouldn't
have been brandishing the guns the way
they were it was very ill advised in
that capacity but should they have been
arrested had their guns seized from them
and the cops will do it with no
questions asked
then you have in Wisconsin this group of
black lives matter activists who had
previously set fire to a home on twice
in one day they start a house on fire I
guess they can't put the fire out in the
neck then after they leave they went and
set fire to it again
then you get this guy sitting in his
house and he sees this group he's got a
shotgun and he and he brandishes it up
at that through his like at his window
his windows closed the police show up
knock on his door and arrest him and I'm
like so here you go let it let it be
known okay if you think you will be
spared by the police you're insane you
are insane we have seen on numerous
occasions with this that's three
examples right now that if black lives
matter comes to your home and I said
this before this guy got arrested I said
it's only a matter of time before black
lives matter will show up to your house
and the cops will look around and say it
is easier to arrest the homeowner than
to deal with a riot and they will arrest
you who did nothing wrong in your own
home now we're seeing examples of this
it was never going to be overnight it
was going to be slowly and gradually and
it's going to get worse and if people
just keep sitting back saying the cops
are on my side you're wrong 100 wrong
it's interesting because antifa or let's
call them Black Blocks these thugs right
they think of themselves as these kind
of revolutionary revolutionaries but in
many ways they're basically just State
sanctioned Thugs and in that sense I
think of of lump and proletariat which
was This this term that Marx used to
describe
people without any real sense of class
Consciousness they're basically just the
term he uses social scum
uh as opposed to actual proletariat and
they ultimately because they're social
scum and they really just want to break
things and they can't they're incapable
of building anything and they're just a
bunch of criminals and degenerates which
is true I mean
so ultimately what they end up being is
tools of reactionary Intrigue and what
he means by that is these These are
people who think that they're involved
in something important but they're not
they're just being used by the state as
as kind of like you know like I said
State sanctioned thugs or I mean uh on
the other hand uh what antifa does
antifa window repair this is great for
the biggest most powerful corporations
in this country it's great for Amazon
when the small brick and mortar business
gets burned To The Ground by antifa it's
great for Walmart when the small shop
gets destroyed and incinerated during
riots this is great Jeff Bezos at the
same time that these riots were
happening last year and people were
having their livelihoods eradicated
Jeff Bezos made or increased his his uh
his worth by 13 billion in a single day
and the reason for that is partly due to
the fact that you could still buy from
Amazon right but you couldn't go to the
local Mom and Pop Shop big box stores
were given special exemptions we saw
this in Michigan where like a local I
can't remember what it was I think it
was like a flower flowers and like plant
shop was like shut down but then the
gardening area of Walmart is left open
so they say well but Walmart sells food
and a lot of people said okay should I
sell loaves of bread at my hobby shop so
I can stay open
well that's that that that's the game
that was being played the massive
transfer of wealth yep but it wasn't
just Democrat uh cities saying we're
going to destroy small businesses at the
same time you had Mass unrest thousands
of people marching to the streets
shoulder to shoulder and what did the
media say what did the universities say
what did the Democrat politicians say
this is not spreading covid your
business is shut down because a little
old grandma walking in to buy milk could
cause the apocalypse but 2 000 people
shoulder to shoulder marching through
New York gets a round of applause from
the doctors we see those stupid
propaganda photos or the nurses like
standing in front of the car and the
woman in the car saying like you know
home for Freedom or something and then
all the people on the internet are like
look at these Brave nurses fighting for
us stopping these stupid anti-lockdown
protesters then a video comes out people
marching through New York thousands and
nurses and doctors walk outside and
start clapping for them and when
questioned they said but racism is the
real Public Health crisis yeah that's
another I mean this is another example
of going back to this discussion about
the FBI and the Capitol Police using
these these fabricated threats to these
exaggerated threats to to justify their
budgets and their operations the CDC
declared recently racism is a public
health threat and they tied it to the
need for more funding right I love it
when the cops all took a knee at these
protests cops FBI National Guard and and
the and like basically pledging fealty
to the extremists and now we're seeing
the implementation of what that ideology
really means in Mark milley Joint Chiefs
of Staff saying like you know getting
full woke but I want to understand this
stuff he says and then you still have
conservatives I'm watching I can't
remember I was watching I was watching a
live stream and people are yelling back
to Blue and I'm like man
pay attention dude those people that
you're defending took a knee for black
lives matter yep
all right support them I guess this
Capitol Police thing's concerning me
there so they got a two billion dollar
just recently uh I think the the funding
yeah the funding was in the last year or
so uh but the point is is they have a
huge War chest who do they uh who do
they serve like who do they report to
well they're supposed to be serving
their their job is to protect members of
Congress right uh so but I mean this is
kind of like I don't know whatever the
local police department here is and then
they say we're going National and we're
expanding our operations Nationwide and
we're also going to be bringing in Army
equipment so are they Federal yeah it's
a federal I'm actually not sure if
they're technically a federal I think
they are it's a federal police force
that they're expanding they're a federal
police force but they're supposed to be
relegated to the capital this is like
another Nation
Oh yeah well I mean you have the I mean
I mean it doesn't like it it's just
sounds like it could become something
like the only issue with dossy thing is
that you already have the NSA CIA the
FBI in about seven seven others to
choose from this could be the Inception
of a federal level police force
intelligence agency Beyond FPS or ice
that's the concern we have this quote
it's from a Newsweek reporting on a
press release from Capitol Police
throughout the last six months the U.S
Capitol Police has been working around
the clock with our Congressional
stakeholders to support our officers
enhance security around the capital
complex and pivot towards an
intelligence-based protective agency the
department said a news release on
Tuesday this was about two weeks ago so
California Florida planning offices
around the country is this uh um you
know like like you were mentioning
earlier in the Mark Twain quote history
doesn't repeat it Rhymes we look back at
um the easiest example of
authoritarianism that is overused by
millions of people World War II Germany
the burning of uh you know the reichstag
yeah and then you had the enabling act
and then all of a sudden these sweeping
laws were not acted opponents of of the
party were being rounded up
you know look a lot of people want to
believe say things like it can't happen
here right
oh it can even BuzzFeed is now saying
that this this Whitmer plot may not even
have happened were it not for the FBI
and I think that's that's an actually
unfair assessment I think the fair
assessment is it would not have happened
right or not for the FBI we're looking
at the Capitol Police in response to one
six Donald we get these news outlets
tweeting Donald Trump's failed attempt
to overthrow the government like they're
just using the most psychotic language
and now we have the law enforcement
apparatus being constructed am I
supposed to sit here and assume this is
not going to be like every past
authoritarian regime that has has used a
crisis to create an ideological law
enforcement force or do I see them
screaming of the of the Insurrection and
then expanding Capital police Nationwide
and think to myself this is a federal
police force that is going to be acting
like an intelligence-based protective
agency how long until they start going
after material support for the
insurrectionists how long until they
start going after the incitement of the
insurrectionist say incitement's a crime
right it's happening now in Michigan
Whitmer State you have the Attorney
General I think Dana nessel is your name
and Republicans supported this by the
way but there's now an effort to
investigate people who are fundraising
on what they on what A.G nessella says
are false claims about the election
being stolen
and in fact this could criminalize
fundraising efforts to secure an
independent election audit in in
Michigan this is a Grassroots movement
that the Attorney General is talking
about potentially they're saying what
they're basically trying to argue is
that if you fundraise off of it it's
fraud fraud that's right so using the
pretext of fraud to potentially crack
down on legitimate Grassroots effort to
secure an election this is this is a
this is in line at the federal with the
federal level with Jen sackey saying
that they're working with phone well she
didn't say this but I should be working
with they're working with Facebook we
got different reports on Politico that
the Biden admin and the DNC are working
with phone companies to police
misinformation you know uh Peter Ducey I
said Steve does he accidentally Peter
Ducey Steve is the guy who's dead I
think Peter Ducey made a really really
good point when he was when he was
getting to the exchange with uh with
jensaki he said there is a video of Dr
fauci from 2020 saying not to wear masks
and it's still on Facebook right now
should that be removed and she
immediately defend offended Dr fauci
well Dr fauci has said the science
change and we all know and then he said
aren't you scared that information you
would have removed today could turn out
to be correct
yeah that's that that's the principled
position but you see when people want
Power they need to stifle and suppress
and control so
here we go man nestled by the days right
she's the woman who uh when this woman
whose restaurant was being affected by
the lockdown started to make a lot of
noise about it and fox was contacting
her about bringing her on to the onto
Carlson show Nestle was the woman who
was asking police if they could quote
just have her picked up before she can
go on Fox
her emails got leaked to the press and
the dating shows that after this woman
I don't remember her name right now was
making a bunch of noise but the
lockdowns and how it's affecting
business after that uh Nestle sent an
email saying can we just have her picked
up before before she can go on Fox so
this woman actually goes on Fox goes on
talking Carlson's show and a few days
after that she's actually arrested what
was she arrested for it was it was some
minor thing I I'm not exactly sure
um but but what's crazy is the fact that
this is a thing that just happens now
right that you can get caught talking
about just arresting someone before they
can go talk to the press and then you
actually do it and it was under under
whatever reason right and then
you it's fine back the blue baby no one
cares gotta back the blue emotional
explanation for that I think I'm not
even sure if what they arrested her for
was even related to like what the fact
that she was like throwing up a middle
finger to the lockdowns uh but but the
point is regardless they arrested her as
Nestles said they should kind of just
send a message right
it's just bizarre to me well I guess
it's not bizarre because it's 2021 but
still it's just it's a thing that
happens and everyone is just fine with
like this yeah this is this is how we do
things now how funny would it be if just
all the populists right conservatives
just started saying we we've all agree
now about the police are the right move
we were wrong like the establishment
left would would flip so quickly they
would be like hell police we love police
yeah hell police Daniel Horowitz this is
a guy at the blaze he is not like he's
not a populist he's he's very much a
traditional unironically principled
conservative again working for the blaze
not a radical Outlet uh and he is he's
actually taken this line defund the
police because he like you he thinks
that like the police are not no longer
actually doing their job they're no
longer actually protecting us from from
crime from violent crime they're in fact
now just kind of acting as the
enforcement arm of the democratic party
it's because I I think for one I've I've
talked to a lot of cops I've gotten
emails from a lot of cops the good ones
quit like right away they were like I
want don't do that that's the line and
now what's left are these like you know
a lot of people who are scared to lose
their job and a lot of cops who aren't
actually doing any work so to those guys
I'm kind of like well you know I guess I
guess when you're taking taxpayer money
and doing nothing it's kind of a problem
but uh it's better than enforcing on
just laws yeah but you do have a lot of
cops who are just like I don't care I'll
arrest anybody that my boss points the
finger at there was that video in um I
think it was Portland I'm not sure where
a bunch of antifar are like walking
towards a guy yelling at him one guy's
got some kind of like stick I don't
think it's a machete I think it's a bar
or something crowbar
and there's a guy walking backward to
the baseball bat the cops grab and the
guy drops the Bat gets on his knees puts
his hands up the cops arrest him and
then apologize to the antifa people yeah
and start saying really nice things I'm
so sorry bro at a certain point these
conservatives need to realize that the
cops are being replaced by black lives
matter and it's funny because when I've
said before you know we should defund or
abolish the police people are like Tim
then National Police will come in and
then the feds will control it all and
I'm like dude
the left already has the police the cops
took a knee they they dropped on there
literally okay you guys ever watched
Game of Thrones bend the knee that was
the line it was like to pledge fealty to
the queen to the Khaleesi What a Sad
What a Sad failure of a show at the end
yeah but but my point is I don't care
what you think bending the knee means
take a knee for black lives matter yeah
they're pledging fealty they did now I
was still willing to be like okay we're
gonna have an election and we'll see
this is the kind of thing that's going
to wake people up and a lot of people
did change their minds Trump got a
massive amount of more votes but the
Democrats did a lot of things in the
lead up to 2020 with with mail-in voting
changes that made it that gave them huge
advantages we saw the article from Time
Magazine and now the police are
comprised almost entirely in my opinion
of people who either don't care won't
work or actually support antifa and
black lives matter in which case call
their Bluff you all are going to be fine
you think I'm worried about it I'm not
most conservatives live in rural areas
why is anybody gonna be worried about it
yeah I guess if you're living in a city
and you're conservative but then you're
giving tax money to these people so we
got to act like we're playing the video
game of civilization right now as well
as living in the country just chilling
we're also communicating to hundreds of
thousands of people creating an an
archetype of what it can be so I don't
want to lose local police because the
federal police will get stronger and
then you do have the SS and like like I
don't know yeah so we so we really
should Empower local police to do the
right thing but they're they're these
cops are too weak well now in some
generalization you know we don't know
them we really don't know we we see a
lot of news articles and make
assumptions so I wrote about in West
Virginia
the a bunch of Sheriff's departments
decided that if if any uh really
restrictive gun control laws would get
passed the sheriffs would find these
different ways to basically not enforce
them there was one Sheriff I don't
remember his name but he basically said
I'm going to deputize every single
person I'm like and and that was that
was Virginia not West Virginia I'm
pretty sure yeah okay Virginia uh I
wrote an article about this for
Chronicles and it was really funny
because the reporter was like wait
so you're saying that you're just going
to make everyone a deputy and the guy
was like yeah that's right I'm just
going to give everyone a badge and then
and then that way like the gun control
laws won't apply to them so there I mean
there are these good people in the local
level but but still I think what you're
ultimately talking about here is this
kind of like attitudinal attitudinal
disposition that conservatives have
where they still feel a kind of
call it blind loyalty to institutions
that either no longer exists or are
actually hostile to them and that and
broadly speaking that institution is the
law enforcement apparat this is a very
uncomfortable place for conservatives
they're conservatives are the Law and
Order people they're the people that you
know that they respect the police uh
they're the ones that follow the rules
they respect hierarchies whether or not
they'll admit it um and now they're in a
position where they're at the bottom of
the food chain
and uh they're being actively persecuted
by the institutions and by the the
people that they think are going to save
I mean there's a common
thing that conservatives say is you know
as bad as things get the military is
going to have our back
Mark milley says yeah Mark milley says
that's not the case and so if you're a
conservative who for your entire life
you've been rah-rah the Pentagon you
know back the blue now like the guns are
pointed at you and I think I think so so
you're right there is uh there's a
discussion that needs to be had and I
think we're only just beginning to have
it about uh the role of law enforcement
right now where it is hyper politicized
and you've got police Chiefs in huge
cities who are no longer really cops
they're just bureaucrats and they're not
in this for Public Safety they're in it
for themselves
Joe Biden was talking about the voting
laws
and he says what we're seeing is the
greatest threat since the Civil War the
insurrectionists reached the capital the
Confederates never did that and you know
we've talked about this a bit in the
past several episodes but I want to add
something to this idea Joe Biden's only
saying these things that paint half the
country as enemies of the state because
he's confident that in the coming years
the this group of people will be will be
figuratively eradicated what I mean by
that is politically eradicated that
they're fractured they can't organize
they won't win elections and their
opinions are completely meaningless
and then it's going to be the overstate
or the cathedral that controls
everything and you look at what's
happened with the police and I think
actually interestingly the resistance of
conservatives is what's helped convert
police departments into woke enforcement
agencies
when the left started saying abolish the
police and defund the police and put
extreme pressure on the police
departments
conservatives stop the Departments from
completely going under by pushing back
and then you had this argument over
whether or not we really want to abolish
police and it worked out really really
well for the woke because then the good
cops were like I'm not going to be a
part of this leave who's left the people
who either don't care or willing to do
whatever they're told and then because
conservatives save the department from
being totally abolished
they were able to restock it up with
cops who know exactly what these uh
modern political times will bear so now
I would only I would only uh speculate
you know we're moving into 2022. we're
going to have the midterms they're going
to be coming after conservatives like
you cannot even believe they they have
already been tweeting things like if we
lose the house it's all over
yes they're Glorious Revolution will be
all over if Republicans get back the
house and can impeach Joe Biden for high
crimes and misdemeanors so what do you
think they'll do they're going to come
after right-wing influencers they're
going to come after anti-establishment
at any capacity which includes some
anti-war leftist types and people like
Jimmy Dore for instance I don't know if
they'll ban him but they've gone after
people in this area who are anti-war
anti-anti establishment Democrat they're
going to try and get rid of anybody who
might actually make them look bad and
they'll do it very slowly if they do it
overnight it'll cause too much of an
uproar but they can't they can't they
can't afford to lose the house yeah I
think you're seeing this with Glenn
Greenwald right he's kind of become a a
bad Lefty because he has joined sides
with the populist right and talking
about how terrible the National Security
apparatus is but but he's he's always
been that right the populist right
finally joined him that's right that's a
good point
um
but here is something to consider is
that I'm not sure that even if
Republicans would resume like assume
power again
it's not clear that it would actually
make a difference because it seems to be
the case that Republicans can win
elections but the left will remain in
control of Institutions right and and
therefore elections are kind of just
they're like respites they're they're
periods where we can catch our breath
maybe plan pressure release yeah that's
all it is but ultimately the trajectory
of the country does not change if we
follow the same trajectory as we did in
the in Trump's first term that is to say
in 2022 Republicans win but then the
Democrats wield the power of the of the
intelligence agencies against
conservatives and and jams them up
investigates and crushes them
Republicans are are at a loss
Republicans don't do this Republicans
don't fight back and then we move into
2023 with the presidency same thing one
of my favorite memes right now is this
idea you hear a lot of Libertarians are
saying things like this they're like the
Democrats think the Republicans are
lying cheating and stealing and
manipulating to gain more power and the
Republicans think the Democrats are
lying cheating and stealing to gain more
power people need to realize you know
both sides that is not true Republicans
don't do anything Republicans have no
cultural institutions they don't have
universities they don't have movies they
got nothing the best conservatives can
muster is Ben Shapiro putting out a
movie and that's great you know respect
for putting on this pronounced movie and
getting into entertainment so they're
actually doing something but
conservatives are not reaching children
they're not reaching young people you
know I I there was a tweet I I think
um I can't remember where I saw this
maybe from Cassandra uh Fairbanks that
Nickelodeon or Disney Channel was
playing anti-trump ads oh yeah she was
talking about that was that Cassandra
Auntie Donald Trump ads on Disney
Channel why those kids will grow up
in 10 years from now those 10 year olds
will be 20 and they are going to be
ideological extremists
and they'll vote and you won't even
realize it some of these kids right now
15 15 years old three more years and
they're voting and you you got to figure
out what these kids are thinking and I'm
sure the Democrats are doing exactly
that and that's why schools are
indoctrinating them because what's going
to happen is you are going to get some
classically liberal leftist and I mean
it actual like Lefty individual who well
I shouldn't say classically liberal
we'll say traditional liberal agrees a
lot of conservatives someone similar to
maybe like me they'll run for office but
in in three to five years they'll be
considered far right like like uh we had
vosh on the show and he called me far
right it was hilarious but he's he's 20
he was he 26 yeah yeah I think so so
these 26 year old lefties on YouTube
think 35 year old Tim Poole who believes
in Universal Health Care and social
programs is far right that's good though
that means you're the Trojan Horse your
controlled opposition no no it means
that in in in 10 more years when or in
even three to five years these young
people are going to come up and they're
going to see a traditional conservative
and think Nazi and they're going going
to see moderate liberal and thank
far-right conservative if it if the
train goes goes as it's as it's headed
but we you know Society is not linear
things don't happen we constantly are
changing the narrative and shifting and
altering the way things are happening
well there there's one thing to consider
and it's that liberals don't have kids
right we're going to outbreed them I
mean this has already happened this is
already happening though right like I
mean when Glenn Greenwald retweets my
stuff or interacts with anything
immediately he's he's labeled as like a
crypto fascist and then people will like
screenshot things that I write and be
like this is who Glenn is promoting this
like fascist authoritarian and stuff and
so I mean it's already happening
um but I think the the
anti-trump ads on you said Disney I
think it was Disney Channel okay
anti-trump ads on Disney is like a good
day for Disney considering all the
others smut that they right that they
run for children and I think this this
kind of got to the issue of like
critical race Theory
where I really appreciate the work
Christopher rufo is like a National
Treasure but I think he has shown that
critical race Theory goes so much deeper
than anyone really thought it did uh and
and that it has already infected every
single cultural and social tissue that
the the task of uh of extirpating
critical race theory is actually much
bigger and much more daunting that I
think anyone had imagined before rufo
came on and came on the scene and
started showing people how pervasive
this stuff is so yeah I want to uh well
actually we'll jump in in a second
um
conservatives need to start producing
culture you know I guess I was trying to
look something up and just we'll pull
that up in a second
if there is something interesting that
we saw with peel research and that is
that the previous generation is slightly
more conservative I'm sorry the Gen Z is
a little bit more conservative than
Millennials but only a little bit and
that's probably has a lot to do with the
fact that you said you know
conservatives are outbreeding liberals
so I have to I have to imagine so I want
to add this to what I was saying before
about you know next three to five years
you might see some dramatic changes
it's entirely possible I'm wrong because
in 10 years the generation alpha or you
know whatever comes after Alpha I don't
know Alpha gen is it is it's Alpha gen
then beta gen yeah they might be
substantially more conservative by
simply the fact that conservatives have
kids so you look at like you know Ben
Shapiro I love it they call them an
incel he's got like how many kids like I
have 12 12 kids
no no he's like four kids
um there's more kids than the people
that call them in so that's true that's
true right right so you know actually I
could be completely wrong you know we
could be 10 years out from a
conservative Resurgence for a lot of
reasons it could be that all of this
stuff with police all of the stuff with
the military is freaking out regular
people come August 15th as Bannon said
we see these these um
in schools the parents freak out at what
their kids are learning and then 10
years goes by and the Millennials are
now in their mid to late 40s and then
the next generation is actually very
woke but
most of that actually most of the
generation actually is more conservative
simply by the amount of conservative
kids are growing up so that's that's a
very real possibility this could be a
fluke reaction is very possible and I as
pessimistic and cynical as I am in the
short term I have to be optimistic about
the future about the long term because I
have kids I've got one who's about a
year old and then I've got another one
on the way in December and so I have to
hold that hope that that something like
this is going to happen because the idea
of just like settling on the on the the
notion that the future will be so much
more horrible for my for my kids it just
seems unacceptable to me so look at what
AOC and a bunch of these leftists are
saying oh we can't have kids because of
climate change it's like okay they're
they're not gonna have kids
conservatives gonna have kids right yeah
and then when they do I mean there could
be this could be actually substantial if
you know you look at Millennials today
not having kids but mostly the left ones
a lot of like non-political people have
kids conservatives have kids Lefty
liberal type Millennials don't have kids
so what happens in 20 years
is this country going to become a bunch
of suit wearing younger young
Republicans well a paranoid mind might
rebut You by saying well this is why
Democrats like open borders because they
can they can import uh new recruits so
to speak so and and why they're going
after schools right they know they don't
have kids so they got to take yours
exactly right yeah one problem I find
with conservativism by the label I guess
is that I think that we need to to kind
of reintroduce or just enforce some sort
of social conservatism in that like you
know we talk a lot about morality and
like not going flying too far off but we
need some like drastic legal liberalism
I think we need to take take Liberty
with our crappy system and change it
um
so
I think conservative politicians are not
getting anything done you know they've
been sitting around just kind of like
enjoying the status quo and that's to
say as much as you need to get elected
then do nothing yeah and we need like
really to alter the system the federal
reserve's gone roughshod
um the central election for three
agencies the police departments yeah
we've got like all these local
governments I mean yeah you know I mean
yesterday's conversation was like
particularly brutal we were talking
about just uh
do these in with with a narco tyranny
keep coming coming up I think a
narco-tyranny is obviously happening
been happening for some years now and I
think that's the easiest way to
understand that the system probably
already collapsed like if if you have
people who feel like calling the place
is pointless legitimately like not like
black lives matter where they're like oh
no I can't call the cops if so you know
no like people legitimately saying I
know they're not going to come here and
deal with this Riot but then also
fearing if the riots attack your house
you will get arrested the system is
completely broken well I think the the
issue with anarcho tyranny is that the
anarco part is by Design it's a feature
not a bug and the point of it is is to
to kind of paralyze the the decent
populous uh into feeling like they can't
do any of the things you just described
they can't defend themselves they can't
have control over what their kids want
in schools and things like that so so I
guess it seems like the system has
failed but it might actually be the case
it's more powerful than ever but on the
other hand historically when when
regimes become more repressive and more
overt in the methods with which they
coerce people to behave a certain way
and to talk a certain way and think a
certain way is usually when they're uh
on the verge of of crumbling or uh
instigating a kind of reaction uh so
because really effective systems of
control are impersonal and automatic so
when you have to start actively policing
people like we're seeing now the Capitol
Police leaving the capital things like
that or the bite Administration talking
about
monitoring text messages things like
that that stuff is as much as it shows
like the power and the boldness of the
established political order it also
tells us that it it's kind of in this
precarious position where it's this
close to maybe overplaying its hand yeah
I think about that with tech censorship
too because we should have a system I
think more that's granular where you can
choose what you see rather than them
choosing what you see the fact that
they're in there deciding who gets to
say what is like yeah they're powerful
but it's also showing how how the cracks
in their system like well you know
they're afraid you look at big Tech and
first I'll just say you're right the
moves they're making show and increasing
desperation and panic and then you look
at big Tech censorship and I can't
figure out for the life of me what their
goal is with big Tech censorship I I
mean this honestly because these are
some of the dumbest they're supposedly
some of the smartest people but boy are
they dumb I mean if you had a sit-down
meeting you could figure out what was
happening in only a few minutes I said
this to Jack Dorsey on the experience
when I was just like at the end of the
show I'm like I'm getting a van and
they're alive they started laughing and
I'm like y'all think I'm joking but I
was like if you keep doing what you're
doing with this with this
hyperpolarization on Twitter people are
going to come to a civil war of star
they're going to go after each other
it's going to be insane so I'm getting
that van ready I'm gonna go bug out and
you know that people were messaging me
laughing saying huh it's so funny I'm
like y'all think I'm joking now now now
look where we are with the police taking
a knee with the riots with covet
everything that's happened since then
has has been a dramatic escalation it's
like I certainly was not wrong I didn't
give a good timeline but you look at
what these tech companies are doing I
couldn't figure it out I can sit here
and say here's what they started doing
in 2000 or in 2010 in 2011 2012 and look
at each year the changes they made
Twitter Free Speech wing and the Free
Speech party they used that to build
themselves up create a platform
then you look at the past several years
they make they make moves to make money
they make moves to hyper polarize what
they are doing is only making things
increasingly worse so the question is is
Twitter trying to stop the polarization
well they're not doing that so it's
still only getting worse and it has been
getting worse okay then they want the
polarization well I I I guess if I had
to if I had to look if I looked at what
they were doing and someone said take a
look at this system and the equation and
the map what is happening I'd say Jack
Dorsey wants a civil war
Mark Zuckerberg and Susan wijicki want
people to literally attack each other in
the streets that's the only thing I can
I can understand from it yeah
so to Ian's point I think you're also
seeing this in the shift toward
antitrust action increasingly
conservatives populists are open to
antitrust action I think part of it is
just a matter of enmity people are angry
right and to your point
Jeff Bezos literally booting parlor off
the internet was probably the stupidest
thing he could have done because what
that did far from killing whatever
narrative was being promoted on parlor
that he thought was problematic I think
was related to the January 6th thing uh
instead it just resulted in more people
than ever especially conservatives who
generally I think would have been
opposed to something like antitrust like
taking a hammer and smashing Amazon are
now all for it you know you're seeing
this now there's no political willpower
to do it no no I I there is absolutely
an effort to kind of throw an olive
branch to the to the populists and say
look we're trying we're trying to do
something we're putting together a raft
of legislation we're trying to take
measures to bring to heal uh Amazon and
Facebook and Twitter and stuff like that
but you're right that there's this kind
of reluctance and a way to to to do
something without actually doing
anything but
I think the the kind of like the cat's
out of the bag and it can only escalate
I think you're only going to see this
trend toward demands for antitrust
action increase at least from
conservatives I think that Liberals are
probably more opposed to it sorry
Liberals are more opposed to it because
uh they're in power right now these
institutions these corporations uh for
the most part they're doing what they
want them to do and so at the same time
that you have conservatives pushing for
Anti-Trust action you have people who
are on the left saying well the thing
that Facebook needs to do is not be
broken up but actually just kick
conservatives off the platform
completely I think gen sackey said
something recently that if Facebook bans
you you should be banned from all
platforms yep I've got some weird
necrotic energy when it comes to saki
lately I've been having like nightmares
about Necromancer yeah like like this
dark dark decaying energy around her
like I've been I think I've been
dreaming about her or like she's been on
in like the back of my subconscious in a
real weird way I'm sorry I'm sorry about
gesticulating by the way it's my Latin
oh no it's fine check this out it's it's
worse than you guys it's worse than you
realize from CNN of all places White
House is reviewing section 230 amid
efforts to push social media Giants to
crack down on misinformation for those
that aren't familiar section 230 is that
beautiful law then allows us the ability
to to use social media platforms without
that platform being sued for what we say
on its surface makes a lot of sense if I
post something on Twitter under my name
y'all shouldn't be able to sue Twitter
for it this law makes it distinction
however the law also grants the ability
of these platforms to moderate at their
hearts to their hearts content in which
case they effectively create an
editorial system by which they can say
we're not Banning conservatives it's
just our rules so they monopolize public
discourse they then start purging
conservatives it creates massive
hyperpolarization it just keeps getting
worse
and then we find ourselves here Joe
Biden wants to get rid of section 230.
Donald Trump and many conservatives have
been saying get rid of section 230 not
realizing the law just needs a little
bit of reform
the Democrats want to get rid of it
because they want to be able to force
Facebook to ban whatever they want you
get rid of section 230 Facebook becomes
liable for all of the for whatever I
said that's wrong for defamation for
even potential criminal uh uh negligent
negligence so I'll put it this way I
like to say hey don't take medical
advice from me talk to your doctor why I
don't want you to sue me some some [ __ ]
is going to do something dumb and then
blame me for it I'm not gonna tell you
to do anything you get people like you
know Ben Shapiro even it's time to get
vaccinated I'm not going to do that I'm
going to say go talk to your doctor
because what if someone says hey Tim
Poole said to get vaccinated I went to a
bar and I was drunk and I got vaccinated
but I was allergic to it nah I'm not
doing that Joe Biden wants to be able to
ban whoever they're going to take away
this law and that's it that's the end of
the internet I will tell you
the one of the most important things
that is keeping right-wing populists and
conservatives in the culture war is the
ability to speak on these platforms they
are trying to take that away by any
means necessary now the problem is many
of these people on the left can't just
outright ban you they can't just delete
Tim Poole and every day timcast.com is
growing and and we're adding more
writers and we're doing more news hey
that's a bad thing if you're trying to
culturally homogenize around this you
know cult ideology of critical race
Theory
the problem is they need a reason to ban
people and they have to do it slowly if
you do too much you shock everybody the
fog got to be blowing in the pot if they
get rid of section 230 they can just say
it's what Trump wanted it's what
Republicans wanted and that's it gone
I think the only the only way that it
would make sense it would be to if you
got rid of 230 would would reduce
Twitter to like a public carrier in
which case it could not ban people but
that's an entirely different argument uh
it's you can read guys like Josh Hammer
who is very much a conservative and uh
maybe more more of a traditional sense
than I am and he's uh he's kind of
suggested this uh common carry would
basically make Twitter into like public
transit system
um so but this is but you're right
though uh as far as the Democratic
party's concerned as far as the by
demonstration is concerned this is what
they see as a pathway to pushing people
like us off of these these channels I
think that's right it will it will bring
us back to the era of a small handful of
channels and it's already been happening
so one of the things that um YouTube has
been trying to do specifically there was
a great Purge that happened I think it
was last year the year before maybe the
year before where they they deleted like
millions of accounts that were too small
banned them from the partner program
they kicked him out of the partner
program
and what this did was it created a an
advertising pool that was very much more
homogeneous you know you had a lot of
channels that made money off Flat Earth
stuff and so YouTube said we're getting
rid of all that stuff some of it was
really dumb some of it was really bad
and I know people who believe stupid
things from watching dumb videos but you
know individual responsibility right
what's happening is YouTube is slowly
Banning more and more channels I hear
about it every day channels getting
demonetized and getting banned
eventually they're trying to get to the
point where there's only maybe a few
hundred channels and all of their
opinions are in alignment for the most
part you got your approved right-wing
opinion and your approved left-wing
position and of course it's all moving
towards the left faster and faster so
you know in 10 20 years potentially the
right-wing opinion will be a leftist
opinion today
many have made that joke that's that's
what that's what they're able to do
because of the lacks rules of section
230. they can effectively editorialize
the same way New York Times will making
money off the content and then assuming
no responsibility for it YouTube did
something interesting a while back they
changed their pay structure to be
royalties and I think the reason they
did that was because of the potential
argument that you could say no YouTube
is effectively employing these people
there was there was you know attempt to
unionize this happened in I think Europe
YouTube unionization there were many on
the left trying to argue that YouTubers
were no different than Uber drivers they
were de facto employees who deserved
rights then all of a sudden YouTube says
now we're paying you royalties for your
content that way
well now you can't argue that YouTube is
publishing the content you can't argue
that YouTube's employing these people
and once again YouTube is now able to
editorialize and manipulate people and
the creepiest thing about it is there's
a small handful of people at the top of
these companies they're as dumb as a box
of rocks they might be good at selling
software or programming but they do not
have the cognitive faculties required to
govern billions of people ultimate
problem is that those people change you
know Larry and Sergey Bale Susan wojiski
didn't exist in this Arena 10 years ago
12 years ago when Chad Hurley built
YouTube before Google bought it and then
changed the ownership again Jeff Bezos
just left Amazon he just stepped down uh
Jack Dorsey owns like five percent of
Twitter he doesn't run that company
anymore he doesn't it's he's a
figurehead yeah they use him to absorb
the criticism while someone else it's
basically a different company but it has
the same name I think that should be
illegal I think in the future when a
company gets sold it should have to
change its name it used to be that
corporations were temporary I'm pretty
sure corporations formed for the express
purpose of a mission and they finished
it and then they broke apart but I'm not
entirely sure I mean companies kind of
existed because people with power had
access to resources and if you did then
you could grant that to somebody and so
somebody would agree to follow you and
then I think what was it for was the
Brooklyn Bridge the first Court version
it could be wrong oh maybe I don't know
yeah I think we need some sort of like
specific law that organizes only around
social media
um and I'm I've been like waiting for
someone to do it and then Joe Biden
becomes president and he's not the guy
and like I'm Will Chamberlain he's the
guy like people like will like we need
to organize some sort of maybe we have
to be the ones just to get creative and
kind of like how do you make how do you
make a law do you just have fun you just
like think about like write a bunch of
stuff down and if everybody likes it
then you propose it to the Senate I was
definitely Wrong by the Brooklyn Bridge
by the way who's the first Corporation
no there was just tons of small
corporations by special legislation yeah
so I'm I'm
you know part of working I co-founded
minds are you familiar with minds.com
I used it briefly it's great and we were
working with like the Manila principles
was just kind of like an internet
constitution for the 21st century about
like free how you can like
keep people free on the internet and you
know I'm sitting here looking like an
idiot because I don't have all the I
don't know I don't know how what the law
should be
I mean if we just reform section 230 a
little bit to say that um they could
only ban speech that was deemed to be
unlawful that Court
or actually they should just be called
common carriers it shouldn't be
incumbent upon the company at all it
should literally be an act of uh law
that removes the content so social media
Network gets x amount of users per day
becomes a common carrier yes and then it
would be like this you post something
and then on Facebook and then people
flag it they flag it to law enforcement
law enforcement then comes in and says
okay we believe this is a you know
incitement or a threat or whatever
there's risks there and you know I've
been a little I I used to be more just
like look there's incitement is unlawful
speech obviously we don't agree with
that and there are some things you
shouldn't say like instructing someone
how to commit a crime and stuff like
that the challenge with that I suppose
is the slippery slope of if unlawful
speech can be banned then the government
need only to clear some speech to be
unlawful right so they can say well look
you know hate speech is not free speech
they've been saying that for a long time
so they pass a law saying hate speech is
not protected anymore and so no you
quite literally can't have a law
supersede the constitution in which case
that makes a very serious conundrum
about laws that are like incitement or
Direction because how can those laws be
uh you know affecting the First
Amendment well to put it simply Supreme
Court precedence is what gave us our
understanding of free speech and it
seems like actually free speeches has
been improving so there are some
questions and challenges there
ultimately I'll put it this way I still
think it's a good idea it can only be
banned by an act of law enforcement by a
court the judges should decide if it
violates some kind of you know law or is
not in the spirit of free speech or
something should be uh I guess up to the
judges to figure out in the way you send
that even with those problems send the
post to quarantine until it's decided
nope so if so say something gets posted
that is illegal it seems very illegal
you flag it that you have to you have to
get a warrant but then if it stays up
while you're investigating it that's a
problem no no it's not they have to get
a warrant and if it's like posting
someone's address and private
information when you know they're at
risk they can get a rushed warrant they
do these things all the time but how
long is that going to take days two
hours even that's a long time for
something to sit up in public view on
the internet because it's actually
copied and pasted and like when you find
illegal content like for mines for
instance it was immediately removed and
then sent to the FBI or whatever but
there's no there's no leaving it up you
can't do that because then it's just
you're you're culpable for inciting
these you know admittedly I guess we're
dealing with a different Arena outside
of just the normal confines of speech
we're talking about people post photos
photos and videos and you know
in that instance
yeah like if someone posted a video of a
crime taking place you know of
themselves committing a crime then there
needs to be the discretion for someone
with immediate access to take that down
or at least quarantine it somehow
the challenge then is you'll get people
in these companies being like that's
hate speech removed and then when you're
like you're not allowed to do it they go
it was an accident and then it comes
back a week later when no one cares
anymore
how you solve for that I do not know got
to remove the human from the uh process
it's it shouldn't be like it shouldn't
be a trust there should be no trust
I think it should be um it should
probably be a warrant issue
um
I mean yeah you you talk about a lot of
things you've seen when you were when
you were moderating Minds imagine if
someone took a picture that like one of
the most disgusting pictures don't say
what it is uh on minds and they put it
up on their window at their house
yeah they go to jail for a lot of this
stuff so if somebody wants to post this
stuff on mines there should be a warrant
an investigation and you know action
taken but it would have to happen
immediately I suppose you can say that
if someone put something up on their
window that was a objectionable like to
an extreme degree the cops would come
and immediately arrest the person and
take it down as the crime is visible but
sometimes someone will put something up
on someone else's window and you're like
well we're not so it's not about busting
that person like
um somewhere like hack into your account
uh well Anonymous accounts for instance
like mines doesn't track people it's
Anonymous so you don't know you can't go
after the individual you just have to go
after the content I think that's the way
social media should function in general
I don't like going after individuals
just ban the channel if that person
wants to start a new channel
if it's criminal and you find out who
does it then they have to face the
penalty of law right but
I don't think that you should Target
like if someone does something that
violates a term on YouTube you ban the
channel That the term was violated on
you don't block that with a constant
from or the content yeah you get rid of
the content itself and allow the person
to in my opinion form another Channel
and if they don't ban if they don't
violate the content again then they're
good to go we we've had an instance here
we uh it was uh January 6 actually we
did our Show YouTube disabled our
comments and our chat because people in
the chat were saying bad things yeah so
they took that down they didn't give us
a track or anything like that and there
are several instances where they said
here's here's we will delete videos that
do these things without issuing a strike
the idea of issuing a strike is
completely broken anyway you know what
strikes on YouTube before direct
provably egregious acts to violate the
rules the problem is what YouTube does
is
someone will uh you know fart and
they'll be like ah gotcha you know or
someone will say something without
intending to break the rules or not
realizing It Breaks the Rules and then
YouTube will be like we're Banning you
for saying that thing instead of just
being like heads up you can't say those
things now that we've warned you any
future instance in which you break this
particular rule will result in a removal
of that content if you directly on
purposefully do this we'll remove you
so we we've had instances I've had
instances where I've had videos removed
without getting a strike and I'll I
message Google and I was I was Furious
uh there's a name you can't say on
YouTube so nobody say it uh and I got
into it with YouTube I was like Rand
Paul is speaking on the senate floor and
you're telling me I can't report this
news you know what I'll say the news
actually we did this in one of the bonus
segments once I just started saying the
name over and over again I'm like we can
do it on our website I was gonna change
my name to that no no no no no no but
what happened in the video just
disappears if I were to change my name
to a band name they would delete the
content all my content like anything I
ever tried to do anything with that name
on it what about the poor person that
has that same name because he's just not
most online anymore yes that's crazy
I've never heard of this before that's
crazy that someone with a word
associated with another word that's
banned can't communicate there is a name
on Facebook and YouTube not Twitter by
the way I feel like Twitter magical fire
right now if you say the word on YouTube
they they they do something special they
don't delete they don't delete the video
in a traditional sense they don't issue
a strike what happened to me was that
the video still was there but it became
I suppose without a graphic instead of
an actual image so if you go to the
YouTube manager you can see a list of
all your videos you can put move them if
you move the mouse over the picture you
know the little you know pointing finger
appears
when I said the name when I reported
this the story because it was big
breaking news
I didn't even know it got deleted until
like a day later someone emailed me
saying hey what happened to your video
and then I went and looked and it was
there and I was like it's still there
it's fine and now when I move my mouse
over it no link no magic pointing finger
just an image just like they didn't want
me to realize it was gone on Facebook
I posted about the guy's name and the
post just vanish instantly
and so I've posted really clever things
that I'm like trying to test the limits
of like the the funny thing is they
can't ban you for it because not a
violation of the rules right they
there's just some there are people who
are working these organizations who have
the ability to remove the name and they
do
that is so bizarre I've never heard of
this before can you write it down and
like slide it across the table we'll
we'll talk about it uh uh for the for
the for the member segment so the the
question of these the heads of these
organizations or these these CEOs who
are kind of disengaged from
Twitter and whatever I think it it's
also interesting because it gets at
another problem that conservatives are
confronting and that is that
the people who are promoting what
conservatives think is socialism also
happen to be the CEO's major
corporations
in other words the the most powerful the
most wealthy people in the country don't
really have a vested interest in private
property anymore and in fact when you
look at the people who are trying to
separate you from home ownership or car
ownership or firearm ownership it
happens to be organizations like
BlackRock the biggest money manager in
the world it's Amazon it's Facebook the
in other words the people that are
trying to deprive you from your property
are the people that we traditionally
would call you know the dirty capitalist
class and again I think this is like the
policing issue this is another issue
that conservatives are confronting with
which they're very uncomfortable because
conservatives are the pro-business party
right the the capitalist party the free
market party
uh and right now the the people at the
top of the so-called free market are
trying to string them up on a noose so I
think this is very this is a thing that
we're uh I think only in the last year
or so have conservatives been forced to
confront this problem of call it Big
Capital you know you know what you know
what I see
the analogy I have for what's happening
is you you you have these uh these
threads all all in front of us
and they're being braided into the
sacred timeline we'll use the Loki
referenced uh when we look ahead there
are a lot of variables in these threads
that will eventually either become
braided into the main line that we're on
or fall off or our timeline and that is
you look at the potential children issue
right conservatives have kids liberals
don't you look at censorship you look at
school indoctrination you look at the
Democratic party you look at the
incitement by Joe Biden screaming Civil
War and it's hard to know how how much
of a role each of these things will play
in the development of our Society or our
timeline if the Joe Biden thing is more
impactful than the school thing then we
may find ourselves splitting into two
threads where we ultimately Clash if the
schools are more impactful then we may
see moms rising up and get a totally
different future it's hard what we can
do is we can see the threads but we
don't know how much of an impact they're
going to have I've noticed we can talk
about a lot of this but our predictions
could be way off we have more power than
we realize that
um you you have massive power massive
massive massive massive it's um we're
altering the timeline so exceed
extremely right now when you it's a
spark Collective Consciousness to spark
like a like a what do they call it when
uh when it hits critical mass it doesn't
take much it just takes it takes
organization of thought like I think if
five fifty thousand people were thinking
something at the same moment
that other people around the world would
start to think it too I don't know about
all that but I can say that the
Standalone complex is a very real
phenomenon if a bunch of rich people are
all thinking if at the same time five
thousand wealthy industrialists see a
news report on CNN where they say far
right extremism on the Internet is
destroying the country
those five thousand people will be
persuaded in some way to take action to
alter What was seen in the news report
That's The Power of media those powerful
people will then all start directing
money not by conspiracy by Standalone
complex all acting individually but such
a way that it appears there was a grand
conspiracy yeah the media is like
allowing people to think the same
thought at the same moment and that's
probably what it's been doing since
radio was invented yep no I think this
this is I mean this happened with the
media itself it's funny the founder of
Chronicles his name was Leopold Tyrone
he's one of the two Founders he wrote
this this essay in The American Scholar
in 1976 I think and the essay is called
the media Shangri law
and Leopold was sketching what we all
know is true today which is that the
media is kind of as an agenda right it's
no longer really in the business of
telling us the truth or merely conveying
information to us but really telling us
how to think about information uh and
and telling us what the truth actually
is
and he says this uh because tiermann was
someone who survived the concentration
camps of the Nazis and the the Soviets
he was a polish jew who survived both
types of totalitarianism during World
War II and he immigrated to the United
States and then founded Chronicles
Magazine with another guy named John
Howard uh and and so he's writing look
uh in Poland the media said whatever the
state told the media to say so so and
everyone knew this everyone in Poland
and everyone who was under the under the
heel of of so of the Soviets knew that
the media would just regurgitate
whatever the party line was and he said
in the United States you have this
unique problem that you can really only
talk about in generalities where it
seems to be that there's this probably
uncoordinated even unconscious effort by
the media to kind of cultivate certain
narratives and basically appoint
themselves as the Arbiters of what is
and it is not true
and this was in the 70s that Leopold was
was saying that uh and it's I mean it's
true he was very pressured and he saw
ahead of it but this gets back to your
point about the Standalone thing I think
when you call it a conspiracy I mean you
might actually be true but I think it's
it's fair to say that this does actually
seem to be a kind of like uh uh at times
almost uncoordinated right uh which
which the point is it makes it very
difficult to fight right because it uh
what do you do about it how do you I I I
think we're very much seeing you know
conservatives are trying to hold on to
institutions and values that they think
make America great and they want to make
it better but the left as we know today
is just like fire
it's just consuming and spreading and
it's fairly directionless you need
destructive interference because if you
say no don't stop that's not that's not
going to solve it that's the big problem
when people are like that's bad I'm
anti-vat that doesn't work you need to
create something new that distorts and
quells the perception of that so that
they're focusing on this now yeah I
think that a problem with conservatism
in the United States is it has largely
been defined by what it's against it's
against socialism it's against big
government it's against you know
whatever but it has hardly put forward
like a positive vision of the country
the left to its credit is I think kind
of visionary the left has tremendous
goals that people will laugh at and
within five years realize oh no it came
true right this is like the story of The
Loft is they get laughed at and then
within a few years uh it seems like it's
it's every uh every time this happens it
seems to take less and less time but
conservatives will kind of guffaw and
laugh and kind of console themselves
that they've got facts and Logic on
their side and then within five or ten
years they're living in the reality
defined by the left yeah and it's part
of the re part of that is the fact that
they have no positive Vision they
basically just uh are happy with these
elegant reprimands of of the
establishment of of the culture and
decline but they don't ever set forth
any alternatives and when you ask them
to or when you do yourself they'll be
the first ones to pick apart why that
wouldn't work why that would make the
government bigger or why people would
just ignore bans on critical race Theory
and stuff like that I mean they do right
but there I think there are actually
ways to enforce these things I mean my
view on critical race theory is not I
think I'm for bands but I'm also for
actually attacking the institutions that
promote these things like I'm uh this is
why I have the idea of eliminating
student loan debt by taking it out of
University endowments which yes kill two
birds Will Chamberlain has been
screaming for some time no it's totally
true I mean but also ngos like I think
NG
non-governmental organizations have made
a kind of Racket out of promoting
critical race Theory I think these also
should be should be they shouldn't exist
I want to share this graphic from this
this cartoon from political humor on
Reddit it says then and there is some
you know white man bearded with a
Confederate shirt and he says we must
preserve Our Heritage and there's like a
Confederate statue of the flag and says
now and it's the same guy ripping up a
piece of paper that says critical race
Theory and he says we must bury our
heritage and then on the Blackboard he's
in a school it says 1921 Tulsa mask
occur and there's a cop writing lesson
banned it's like
it's all it's almost as on the nose as
Ben Garrison's comments and there's like
sad little kids of varying races looking
at him doing it in the sad you know
black teacher and I'm like the funny
thing is they rely on false arguments in
an effort to push back as if James
Lindsay is a Confederate like
Christopher Ruffo James something
Christopher the most prominent voice as
opposed in critical race Theory have
literally nothing and nothing to do with
an old white man wearing a Confederate
flag yeah James Lindsay actually in a
moment of confusion attacked me as as I
think a promoter of critical race there
because I made a joke about how some
Latinos are like white adjacent and he
attacked me he like attacked me because
I don't know I think he thought I was
like a critical race theorist or
something but uh no you're right I think
Lynn Lindsay is one of these guys who's
I think he's just like a liberal isn't
he like a classical liberal traditional
he's harmless Classical liberalism is
more like libertarianism he's totally
harmless and yet because he argued that
look The Logical conclusion of telling
people that whites are the root of all
evil and are to blame for everything in
the words of Suzanne Sontag if you know
who she is so that the white race is the
cancer of human history if you tell this
to people
you're going to start seeing an increase
in violence against whites just like you
would against any group you know it's
who lacks sure sure but you're also
going to see a rise in white racial
identitarianism of which critical race
theorists are actively calling for right
now well the the yeah the weird D'Angelo
thing but the point is is that when
Lindsay just made this harmless
observation he was attacked uh as
promoting like a the white genocide
conspiracy theory right right right
right that's the weirdest thing but
wasn't it by Colette yeah uh Claire
Lehmann or lemon whatever her name is uh
yeah well that's become like
particularly establishment
pro-establishment isn't it very strange
right yeah because it's it's like
adjacent to the IDW uh but I mean look
the whole like identitarian thing is is
if you're going to have a society where
you have the Hispanic caucus and the
black caucus and every group is allowed
to have an identity and as part of that
a sense of dignity like it's okay for me
to be black or it's okay for me to be
Hispanic or whatever and you deny that
to whites
do you see the problem with this do you
see the problem with having a black
caucus and Hispanic caucus but then you
tell white people you're not even
allowed to think of yourself in terms of
of a member of a group like it's uh it's
a it's a kind of problem that creates
itself so I think I'm not sure who but
somebody uh rather mainstream I think
Dave Ria boy yeah made this argument
recently like look you you literally
can't have this Society it will collapse
on its own terms and I agree with that
one thing about critical race Theory
I've been thinking a lot about is I see
this push to ban it to make it stop like
stop make it go away no no more no more
that's not gonna work because I do agree
that we shouldn't be indoctrinating
children with a racial theory in school
but we need to educate people about what
critical race Theory or critical theory
is implicitly well if we know what it is
we know what to look out for well hold
on
when I grew up I was told by my teachers
classically liberal ideas I was told not
to judge people based on the content of
their character or the color of their
skin the T the schools told kids this
and it was accepted they said not to be
um you know hateful or homophobic and
all this stuff today the teachers are
saying they want that the kids should
judge people based on the content of
their character I'm sorry they should
judge people it's in the on the color of
the skin and not the kind of another
character the point is even if you say
we're Banning critical race applied
principles the teachers still will say
these things and still believe these
things that's it that's then they should
lose their in my opinion
this is I fully support a ban I support
firing teachers to promote this stuff I
support seizing the endowments I support
destroying ngos but financially no no no
no now think about when when uh you know
the Civil Rights Movement was happening
it's this is the trouble with Banning
ideologies religions can be defined we
know you know religion there's an
interesting debate about intelligent
design versus uh Evolution and people
are like intelligent design is just
religion because it's not in science the
problem is you can easily make something
an ideology then how do you ban it you
tell don't tell the kids to believe
things about race you said racial Theory
well Martin Luther King Jr's theory on
equality was a racial was was a racial
Theory I understand critical race
applied principles are very specific and
it's a specific ideology but how do you
ban an ideology how do you separate
ideology from public institutions you
don't think educate people about what it
is first so that they know that's a big
part of it um I think it is it is easy
to say we have the 1964 Civil Rights Act
and creating racial groups as a
violation of of title I think what is
that nine Title Nine in colleges
particularly I I would actually argue
that critical race theory is an
outgrowth of the Civil Rights era and
the primary function of CRT today is to
explain why disparities have persisted
despite the Civil Rights Act sure but
Derek Bell opposed civil rights
Derek Derrick Bell was was critical of
Democrats this this is where uh I'm I'm
fairly sorry I I I I could be wrong so
Factor me on this one but my
understanding is that Bell was operating
the idea that you know Democrats were
effectively uh taking agency away from
the black communities and forcing them
to co-exist underneath I I got to go
through the literature specifically on
Bell but my understanding is critical
race theorists effectively oppose civil
rights and one of the things that he
that I've seen emerge out of black lives
matter uh the black lives matter
movement specifically this was in I
think Ferguson Ferguson and Baltimore
was this idea that segregation was a
good thing and these were black
activists saying it they believed that
before the end of segregation they were
equal and opposite communities in which
you had black families black businesses
Black Wall Street segregation forced the
black community to live underneath the
existing white infrastructure effect you
know effectively making them
second-class citizens I'm pretty sure
that was a lot of those ideas came from
Bell
yeah and that's why one of the one of
the big criticisms of critical race
theory is that the goals of critical
race Theory are to rewind the clock back
before the Civil Rights Movement so
that's why you see things like caucusing
they want racial segregation that's why
you see an attempt to repeal
California's civil rights provision in
its own in their constitution so that
they would have the right to
discriminate on the basis of race and
other things it's why you see actions
from the left with Harvard they need the
ability to discriminate on the basis of
race which means repealing the 1964
Civil Rights Act they oppose it and they
always have well the thing about I mean
this is the thing about the CRA is that
it actually has codified and
institutionalized discrimination against
whites it has by and it has has done
that by basically advantaging and giving
every other group except for white uh
White's preference and access to
different affirmative action programs in
effect it discriminates against no no
affirmative action it's actually been
argued a violation of the 1964 Civil
Rights Act particularly
um with Harvard you cannot discriminate
on the basis of race one of the ways
they've gotten around this is that the
courts ruled this was particularly
recently in in Southern California that
so long as you offer up an equal uh
program for other groups it is not
discrimination specifically if there is
a woman women in computers program and
uh there was a man who sued they said is
there a men's computer program yes okay
it's not discrimination the problem with
that argument is
the the that's the argument for
bathrooms if you're offering up an open
bathroom to all then anyone should be
able to use any you know or I'm sorry
it's if uh
the the problem with that argument is
the racial argument if you're creating
you know a whites only or you know a
Black's only area providing free but
separate access was one of the critical
arguments from the Civil Rights area
that ended segregation so ultimately
long story short without getting too
complicated the critical race there SWAT
segregation they can't have it so long
as a Civil Rights Act says you can't
discriminate on the basis of race so in
California they had I think it was
Proposition six I could be wrong where
they maybe it wasn't six I'm not sure
where they wanted to remove from their
constitution the public civil rights
provision that said you cannot
discriminate on the basis of race you
know uh sex national origin religion in
in schools in public Contracting and
employment they tried to get rid of that
recently I think just this past November
it failed because people of California
were like why would we get rid of our
civil rights
yeah I think you can find these examples
of these situations where people can
successfully I guess find recourse
against this stuff to the CRA but I mean
the fact is is that affirmative action
things like that is actually the
outgrowth the CRA and I mean but that
makes no sense it does when you consider
that the that the provisions of the
Civil Rights Act were intended to kind
of like
were intended to let's say catch blacks
up and other initially blacks but the
provisions ended up extending to uh to
homosexuals to immigrants into women but
the reason California that the Democrats
are arguing they can't Implement these
programs because of the Civil Rights
provision I haven't heard that argument
you need to read about the prop uh let
me see my point is is that you're you're
right there probably are these instances
where people say these things but
generally speaking the legacy of the
Civil Rights Act has been the cultural
affirmative action I think and part of
it's confusing because
people thought no it wasn't prop six
that's that was Road repair people
thought they were going to get this
colorblind thing right and when you look
at like the rhetoric of MLK you also see
that there's the famous 16 maybe it was
a famous quote judging people by the
content of the character inside the
color of their skin but MLK explicitly
supported affirmative action programs he
saw no contradiction between something
like the Civil Rights Act and
affirmative action 16. I was wrong it
was it was probably in 16 proposition
six was like the Rhodes
repairing act or something like that
anyway
um it's it's called the affirmative
action Amendment
Federal level Democrats came started
campaigning on behalf of California
saying California should have the right
to discriminate on the basis of race in
schooling and public jobs for the sake
of fixing racial disparities it uh it
got 57 42 percent 42.77 voted Yes on
Prop 16 in November November 3rd 2020.
57.223 said no 9.6 million people said
no to prop 16 keeping California's civil
rights provision in their constitution
making affirmative action
unconstitutional in California
yeah no I'm not not denying that you you
have this example but I think you can
find plenty of counter examples one of
the reasons that the 1986 immigration
reform Control Act was on basically
unenforceable was actually because of
Civil Rights Act because there was this
problem where businesses enforcing the
provisions of the immigration controller
form act would potentially run up into
anti-discrimination laws or part of the
Civil Rights Act so this is it's like an
unintended well
I think in some ways it's an unintended
consequence but it's it's The Logical
conclusion of making anti-bias and
anti-discrimination the the sen the
central principle of your politics is
well
why are we why are we waging this war
against discrimination well it's because
one group is discriminating against all
the rest and I'll say this too there's
almost no hard principle for
anti-discrimination so when we look at
the 1964 Civil Rights Act we ultimately
will just make a personal decision as to
where we stop if we truly believe you
can't discriminate against people based
on certain immutable characteristics or
certain personal characters or
characteristics or identities
it goes infinite yes that's right
furries New York says says gender
identity is self-expression by which
legally furries would be protected and
so ultimately the 1964 Civil Rights Act
is really about society and what our
social norms are and are willing to
accept we we gotta go to super chats
because we are running late so if we
haven't smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and go to timcast.com
become a member there will be a bonus
segment a members only podcast coming up
around 11 but let's read some of these
super chats
Louis uh castagliola says how many plots
and conspiracies supposedly stopped by
the FBI would have even gotten that far
without instigation by government malls
and informants I guess the the the
answer to that is many of them if not
most
Cecil Rhodes says FBI fabricating bias
investigations whoa
all right let's see corny says the
website is totally broken comment
section is gone videos is 50 wide and
website is plastered with ads there are
no ads for members
um and the there's a uh if you are
experiencing a bug with your video this
comment section and the videos then you
need to press like Ctrl F5 or something
to hard refresh because those were bugs
that we sorted out on Saturday perhaps
people need to refresh the the cash I'm
not entirely sure yes clear your browser
cache that's a good way to do it yeah
and the other thing too is uh members
don't see ads uh if we're going to be
hiring journalists and having articles
for people to consume but they're not
members we have to support that somehow
so obviously they're ads but if you're a
member there should there should be no
ads there are some bugs don't get me
wrong we're working to fix all of them
some people are still experiencing some
of these things but um we'll we'll you
know do our best to get everything
sorted what about comments are they
coming on you said there were comments
still comments are gone yeah I don't
have comments on mine and maybe it's
because I haven't refreshed my camera
maybe it's a bug thing okay yeah I saw
all the old comments were still there
but but again if you're not seeing them
then we'll just I send a message and
then we'll figure out what a wonderful
world of tech this is what happens we
were in Alpha we go to Beta now we're in
public beta and people are gonna notice
problems and so I apologize but man that
site is cool dude it's well organized
yeah I know it's it's it's it's getting
there we're gonna have new shows it's
gonna be fantastic
but we'll get it fixed Courtney I
apologize for for any of the issues uh
and if and people who don't like ads
um become a member you know support our
work because you'll get access to all
the members only stuff I just wanna I
wanna I wanna just say something really
quick too
guys you got to realize
um hosting this content the images and
the videos it's absurdly expensive you
know YouTube cheats
YouTube this this live stream would not
be possible on a private server it would
cost so much money YouTube plays games
Google subsidizes YouTube so we you know
we had a peak of like you know 32 or
something thousand people watching we're
streaming what's what's our rate we're
at
2 600 kilobits per second multiplied by
all multiplied by the upstream and the
downstream if we were operating that on
our own the bandwidth bandwidth costs
would be insane
so we got it you know ads ads are a
thing that happened on websites but we
we want to make a reasonable service and
you know that's the way it's got to be
we're hiring journalists we got to pay
them in order to pay them we either run
ads or we take memberships but I you
know it's all working out really well so
I apologize for people who don't like
ads but uh got to support the business
all right let's see
Aaron well beloved says Ian for
president of the universe
well I don't know if we if we need one
person to run everything anymore maybe
we can decentralize the power structure
no I'm pretty sure that if Ian got a
hold of the The Infinity Gauntlet he
would be worse than them no I would be
like Adam Warlock dude I'd pull a George
Washington
Cincinnati what is what is that yes Adam
Warlock he took he got a hold in the
comic book which is the the real
Infinity Gauntlet story uh he got the
gauntlet and then he gave the gems to
the infinity watch to take them and then
spread out across no you'd be a zildor
and I'd be like do it in take the gems
out give them to the Watchers and you go
no I found no you're like Frodo I'm like
oh Tim no no and you're like it's mine
oh mine I keep thinking like are we
gonna have a Frodo Sam moment where
you're standing there with the ring and
I'm like throw it up you know you know
why I wouldn't uh you know what I would
do if I had The Infinity Gauntlet I'd
like just make like weird little things
happen that don't really change much
because what you got to understand about
life as much as you might not be happy
with life think it's unjust or want
things you ever play a video game you
ever play like you know and you put in
the cheat codes you get so bored so fast
like it's it's a fun novelty for a few
minutes while you're playing Mario with
infinite you know leaf or whatever P
wing and Mario 3 and you can't die you
got game genie on or you're playing uh
let's say Fallout or some console game
and using console commands it's fun for
a second when you like make you know I
play Fallout 3 and I'm like make my dude
80 feet tall and I'm running around and
you know make them run super speed and
then eventually I'm like me I I won't
set up a private server uh or no no I
didn't somebody set up a private server
on Warcraft we went on and they gave us
GM commands and I was like this is so
cool we're teleporting and we're like
shooting through the air and then I was
like this is dumb so you think the game
anymore that are running the world if
there is such a thing a deep state or
whatever do you think that they've also
become disillusioned bored with
everything and now they're just
that's why they probably resort to
profound depths of generacy like Jeff
Epstein I really think that's a thing
that if once you become that wealthy and
that powerful like you can only feel
something when you engage in some kind
of depraved act yeah I don't want that I
don't want that level love though
desensitization do you guys hear the
Democrats are planning to make women
register for the draft yeah I do not
draft our daughters that alt-right Meme
I wrote about Ricky Van do you know who
he is no okay he was like oh yeah I
vaguely remember right he that was one
of his memes draft our daughters
well Supreme it's real now Supreme Court
said it wasn't uh got sued they said it
was an it was uh incumbent upon Congress
and now a Democrat from Rhode Island is
saying women should have to register for
the draft I support that but I support
it because it is horrible and it should
be taken to its hyper logical conclusion
which is drafted orders I bring that up
though because we have this uh Super
Chat from Hunter Ryan female veteran yes
we should register and yes we should be
allowed any job we meet requirements new
PT test MOS scale not gender check the
email
um my argument is basically I don't care
if you're a man woman uh uh if you're
from this country or that country so
long as you are a citizen obviously well
actually I think there are some people
who are citizens who are not citizens
who are in the armed forces regardless
if you meet the qualifications and you
can do the job I don't care about your
identity you know what I mean
there you go
so yeah uh draft for everybody force
them all you know I'll say this though
how much you want to bet
you are in favor of the draft
me personally yeah both you guys I'm I'm
opposed to both which would the draft
the uh I'm opposed to the draft
unless in some kind of tremendous
circumstances like an alien invasion uh
and I I mean My Views on um oh okay well
let's let's break this down uh if
somebody broke into your house would you
take up arms to defend your house
yes if you got word that antifa was
heading to your neighborhood to your
block where you lived with weapons and
your neighbor said we need your help
we're going to be standing guard at the
front of the street you need to help us
would you go and help them yeah
so you're being drafted by them well
neighbor watching I would be I would I
mean it depends I guess I don't know if
you'd call that a draft because it's
entirely voluntary uh I don't know I
think my opposition to the draft is
actually fairly new for most of my life
I supported it but I guess knowing what
I know now about the federal government
uh I couldn't support the draft for like
Iran or something right well that's
exactly my point if you got word that
China had invaded the west coast and
seized Seattle San Francisco L.A and was
basically wiping out and seizing full
control and then you know a local uh you
know military called up and said you
have to join we need you this is it our
our country is under attack would you be
okay with that yeah that's different
from Vietnam exactly right and so the
problem with the draft is that they're
like hey we're not at risk but uh go
blow up those people and we're like nah
so the problem is the idea of a draft in
defense of a country for truly defending
it I think most people probably would be
okay with the problem is most of our
drafts of the past 100 years have been
like go to some foreign land where
someone who didn't attack us is you know
we need to attack for some reason yeah
that's right yep all right let's read
some more
all right let's see bang switch Tickler
says the FBI has always been a corrupt
agency the legacy of Woodrow Wilson and
Jagger Hoover lives on to this day in
that trash agency
John tarwood says I'm excited to see how
many registered voters used California's
Capitol building's address to vote
oh
just jumped on us
Eric Ace has abolished the FBI they've
long outlived their original emergency
purpose for their creation and to keep
finding justifications for their
existence and budgets abolish the FBI
except The X-Files they can stay huh I'm
kidding I think X-Files are real though
right it's what they put on things where
it's like weird and they don't know what
happened I think they are yeah and
that's where the basis of the show was
they were like oh let's make a show
about that
all right
Jonathan Duggar says Jewel was a guard
of the 1996 Olympics in Atlanta the
Atlanta Journal Constitution named him
as a suspect and the FBI was doing
everything they could to Target him
Jewel died a few years ago with an
without an apology from the AJC fake
news wow
yeah insert name here says NorCal here
welcoming a balkanization of Cali NorCal
hasn't considered itself to be the same
state as SoCal for some time PS we have
80 of Cali's water supply let that water
black hole LA turn into a sand pit which
it would be but I believe La gets a lot
of their water from the Colorado River
yeah jerks yeah still in our water yep
okay
let's see
I don't know what that one means I'm
gonna skip that one
Jacob Howard says
can we please call the Capitol Police
Biden's Stormtroopers
Stormtrooper sounds too cool yeah yeah
it's it yeah it's like invoking fun
excitement and Star Wars and you know no
you know you gotta give them stupid
names like silly nannies you like you
know like a Family Guy joke or the the
the the whisper the the the the kid
sniffers
yeah kid sniffer cops
the the uh Capital kid sniffers yes yes
that's you know
it's fair
it's
fair
David Bowyer says the issue I see is
that we live in the United States which
is full of many cultures whether it be a
gamer culture or a gun culture or Sports
culture so when people say we are losing
the culture War are we really yes so
when like oh man I love this I said
years ago I was like just you wait once
they start once Major League Sports Go
woke because we're seeing it in video
games and movies and then it happened
and then the polls came out and the
ratings were sinking and they're just
miserable because nobody wants to watch
woke sports but I tell you this it ain't
over yet just wait until they say
sporting rules are arbitrary
sport Major League Sports should be
required to have a certain percentage of
female players
why not
nva's rules are made up we made them up
we could we could absolutely add a new
rule saying at least you know half the
players in the team got to be women I
think when you when you force equality
of outcome like that you cause a lot of
tension among the people that you're
forcing into the situations like I don't
want the male athletes to start hating
the female athletes for bringing the
team down
yeah and I think that the way to think
about the culture war is not we're
losing its that we've lost well what is
the war what is the goal of the war the
goal of the war is to take control of
certain narratives about important
issues about race about gender about
national identity about American history
and on those categories I think concert
you can confidently say conservatives
have lost they have no control over
these narratives and how to cultivate
them and and how to direct them I think
that when you start from that position
we've lost then you ask yourself why did
we lose and I think that's the question
that we should be asking ourselves if
you're a conservative or like Tim a
disaffected liberal all right Justin
silver and says I'm skeptical about the
freedom phone look up the Anam sting
police sold encrypted phones and tracked
crime and made arrests more Luke please
well you gotta tell Luke to come on the
show because he's off gallivanting about
New Hampshire with his free free state
project but uh that's pretty cool anyway
though
um the freedom phone I'm going we're
going to we're going to you know
we're gonna rip the shreds yeah we're
gonna get a hold of it and we're gonna
do a bunch of forensic testing we're
gonna do we're gonna look for data
leakage and things like that and we're
gonna see uh you know what's up and that
means we're gonna need to get a couple
different versions of them and then uh
you know we got we have to figure
something out but I I want to genuinely
test this to see if it's on the level
because you never know I mean this dude
Eric might be a good dude but what if in
the manufacturing process someone you
know bugs them yeah well I was I mean
something I read about them was that
their pop like this specific model is
popular in places like North Korea
because they can be tap they can
basically be accessed by state agents in
other words not very secure and I mean
you go to the freedom phone website
there's no specs yeah on the phone and
the phone is in fact manufactured by
it's it's a Uma Digi yeah which
basically Mass produces uh customizable
phones
well that's not surprising to me at all
though right no someone's lying trying
to look for a low-cost model to make a
phone they find a company that makes
low-cost phones right but it's being
marketed as like a revolutionary
security thing which is so he's got a a
custom operating system on it we have to
do a forensic analysis to see if his
claims are true right but you know the
the smear campaigns against Freedom fun
have been hilarious because they don't
actually smear anything about it they're
like aha he used the base Chinese phone
model and I was like okay what's the
operating system yeah well good for you
that you're actually willing to you know
put it under the knife before you make
your criticisms well I mean what what
can you criticize yeah you know what I
mean I can be like you got to put the
specs up bro where are the specs at I
think it's going to be I think it's the
what is it the something for it's like a
like they have the five now five a out
but it's like the four version four so I
have a feeling it's proclaiming it's the
Uma Digi A9 okay it'll be like a
slightly less technical equality version
of what you know Google and apple are
making with slightly more security is
what my guess is what it's going to be I
I think the device is going to work as
advertised I think that's right because
it would be hilarious absolutely
hilarious and I'd love to be the person
to dig this up if I buy a stock Freedom
phone run some basic forensic analysis
and find that it's sending all my
information to the FBI I'd be like how
dumb was that and then I'd post it
everyone would be like wow so there's
there's no way you can put out a phone
that doesn't do what you're saying
because people can just check it it
would be like if someone said I'm gonna
sell you a a Frisbee and they give you a
rock you'd be like dude it's not a
prison this is not a frisbee it does not
Glide did you throw it yeah you throw it
then it hits the ground you're like I
can clearly tell this thing is not a
frisbee you know so I guess the
difference is it would be like you know
trying to buy a baseball bat and sell
you a wiffle bat you know you look at it
from a distance you might be like that's
a bet then you pick it up and you go
wait a minute the moment you hold it
you're like what so maybe it maybe it's
not as good as they say it is and it
won't do as advertising the guy will
make a bunch of money or um then people
will probably get refunds so you know
we'll see if he's definitely I don't
think he's doing it for the money he's
already severely wealthy
Louis T says Ian you are the cilantro in
this guacamole thank you sir I don't
know if that's a good thing yes I don't
like cilantro sort of racist comments
I do not like cilantro I know that's why
I'm here to him and people are people
people are like it tastes like soap and
I'm like I didn't say that I just don't
like it it does not taste like soap
that's the weirdest thing to me like
what soap are you talking about right
cilantro soap yeah I mean yeah like
because you could take that because I
you know there's there's cucumber melon
soap there's lavender and it all just
soap just tastes bitter like you ever
get snow soap in your mouth or something
just bitter her cilantro Does that taste
like so just tastes like cilantro it's
very unique doesn't like there you go
yep
there was a principal defense of
cilantro I love it I love the medicinal
quality of food I was actually thinking
about the Hippocrates quote let food be
thy medicine and I was like actually I
posted that Meme at what point will
social media networks start to say this
is misinformation about health and I'm
like what I'm posting a 2000 year old
quote from the father of modern medicine
well he was food is your medicine he's
probably a bad guy Christopher hunt says
the left does have kids yours also
antifa is the outer class brought to you
by Victory Windows Glass and paint there
you go that's right they have your kids
in schools that's why the school thinks
it's a hot button issue to them right
right that's why they have to lie about
the these you know critical race theory
in schools we're just teaching racism
that's why we have to homeschool that's
right correct
all right let's see
what is this
James Coleman says dude Tim WTF I pay
for your website why am I seeing Harris
on BTE instead of your members content I
am effering angry like what does that
mean Harris on BTE behind the I don't
know I don't know what that means I
don't know we're trying to fix the bug
so we do have bugs we'll sort it out
Scott says Tim you want to put social
media punishments in the hands of law
enforcement 20 minutes ago you said to
abolish the police because they they're
so biased the only solution is
unmonitored free speech
um I also mentioned that the abolishing
the police thing was twofold partly
because it's becoming corrupted it's not
actually fulfilling its purpose and
we're facing a narco tyranny and the
other is that the left like regular
people would instantly snap to attention
if the police went away but the hands of
law enforcement for social media yes
because I I believe if we have a
functioning society and we're hoping
that it does continue to exist then the
only people should have any way to
remove content should be for legal
reasons
and I also said it was for the courts
too so law enforcement cops maybe not
the same thing maybe Marshalls do it or
something no what you said is consistent
I think
all right
let's see what is this Derek Lola says
my father and I bonded plenty over
watching this show the past year he
passed away last week and I wanted to
thank the entire team for providing us a
great medium to enjoy together Derek I
am sorry to hear about your loss but I'm
I'm glad you guys enjoyed the show
together and I greatly appreciate your
Super Chat and your viewership I wish
you the best thanks for sharing that
casual gorilla says gorilla rise up
oh yeah AMC stock bounced you know yeah
I've got some I've got some AMC stock I
just you know got some and I was like
that's fun and I just kind of forget
about it you know what like one share
you're rich now
well if if it's going to get as crazy as
they think it's going to be it might end
up becoming worth an obscene amount of
money I thought that was hilarious like
everything about the whole game stock
thing was absolutely fantastic yeah
it's all about it Antonio calabresi says
Tim had to get this in during the prop
16 talk please look at the California
map to show Which counties voted yes it
is quite telling it is in the SF and LA
area
I'm not surprised the leftists want
segregation they've wanted it for some
time I experienced it personally and
Occupy Wall Street
the only way they're going to get it if
they can actually discriminate
Mr beard says I ordered a Raspberry Pi
from Amazon on Saturday to load a DNS
server called pie hole for blocking ads
across this whole network after ordering
I noticed that I also ordered speechless
that got added to my cart by Tim on
Friday yes
So what had happened is we were doing
the show and I said Alexa order
speechless by Michael Knowles
and it did it again
oh no she's gonna order the moles Alexa
stop
oh she's she's not listening stop
somebody super chatted something shoot
it and then someone super chatted that
with your flintlock pistol oh there you
go so somebody super chatted that sent
that phrase I'm not gonna say it again
and I was like oh this is too good to
miss I'm gonna read this Super Chat and
then but so I went uh uh I was ordering
what was I ordering I was ordering an
incubator for the chickens and
speechless was in my cart
I was like I already have a signed copy
I'm surprised that you use Alexa I'm so
paranoid that I have like disabled
Cortana on my laptop and stuff oh yeah I
got microphones and everything but you
know my thing is like all of my opinions
are recorded and broadcast for the world
that's true for hours it's not a secret
right yeah yeah I was outside in the
yard and I was like Alexa what time
I can only imagine that like NSA cifbi
whoever else is spying they're like
sitting back and they got like a Slurpee
and like they're just like you know we
don't got to spy on the guy because we
just watch his show yeah you know we
know what he's saying yeah but then
maybe when they spy they get the juicy
private Vlog details because they know
they're like you know they know what the
vlog's gonna be before the Vlog goes up
and they're like dude so the inmate
bread again right so the NSA has like
early access to your [ __ ]
yeah
all right
um I can't read the name uh this guy's
name is not readable on YouTube he says
I can neither confirm nor deny that I
was involved in making up an erroneous
story in attempt to get Trump impeached
salty Army as Legion the salt must flow
re
yes there is a name that can't be said
I'll tell you what for all the people
who don't know the story
here's gonna happen
I'm sorry oh wait what is this Jim
Ariola says hey Tim your most recent
members podcast is now showing a Kamala
Harris video for nine seconds we will
get that fixed immediately what um I I
did I did check all of I went through
everything this morning and everything
was fine but things probably are popping
up because you know the bugs try and
sneak through for all those who want to
know what this name is what is this name
what is the thing it's the first thing
I'm going to do when we open the members
podcast today I'm just gonna say it and
then explain it briefly and uh a lot of
people probably don't know probably a
lot of people who do and you know but I
can't you can't say the name you can't
say am I gonna be disappointed that it's
like not someone who's super based yeah
yes you're gonna be disappointed very
crushed it's just it's just confusing
yeah you know we hear that you know
communist China is censorship and all
this stuff and I'm like bro I can't you
can at least say Mao's name you can at
least say XI jinping's name maybe like
Grover Cleveland something like that
yeah stop trying to guess the name it
reminds me of the Futurama episode where
Bender has the code word that if he says
it if the code phrase he'll blow up oh
yeah and they couldn't remove the bomb
so they're like we just change the
phrase to something you almost never say
because also they put a bomb in him and
it goes off when he says the the most
common phrase which is you know bite my
shiny metal a and then they they're like
we couldn't remove the bomb so we just
changed the trigger to a word you almost
never say and then he starts he's like
oh is it this and they're like Bender
it's not trying to Guess The Word Guess
The Word and he goes antiquing
anyway my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel you can follow the show at
timcast IRL on Facebook and Instagram at
timcast underscore IRL on Tick Tock if
you so desire and you can follow me
personally at timcast we're gonna have
that members podcast up around 11 or so
p.m so make sure you go to timgas.com
become a member check it out Pedro you
want to shout anything out yeah uh
follow me on Twitter at
e-m-e-r-i-t-i-c-u-s and the most of my
writing you can find at
chroniclesmagazine.org I've got a
newsletter too at
contra.substack.com I run a podcast
there and I try to bring on interesting
guests and I send out weekly roundups of
all of my work like this stuff and
articles that I write so yeah right on
right on man follow me at Ian
crossland.net and at Ian Crossland on
social media and be good to each other
you guys may follow me on Twitter at
Sour Patch Lids as I attempt to achieve
my lifelong goal of having more
followers and Sour Patch Kids that's all
I want in life please help me we will
see you all over at timcast.com in the
members only podcast and I'm gonna make
some phone calls trying to fix those
bugs immediately thanks for hanging out
we'll see you all there